sometimes I wonder if we are all
connected by some kind of
Universal magnetism or vibration that
permeates our being and transmits ideas
and feelings among everybody
I wonder that same thing that's right
and uh the reason is it really does feel
like this ridiculously slow news day
like none of the news is moving me
despite the fact that we've got a new
report that the Biden another member of
the Biden family was receiving cash from
China despite the fact that Poland is
sending fighter jets to Ukraine
dramatically escalating the war causing
World War III to Trend all of this is
happening and everybody kind of feels
like nothing is happening and I'm like
why is that shouldn't we be like holy
crap this whole thing is imploding the
banks are failing or maybe
the bubbles burst right we've been
inundated with too much all at once and
now no one cares at all World War III is
happening the banks are collapping the
Biden family is crooked and taking
communist money and then everyone goes
hey
what am I supposed to do about it so
there are your stories for the day we'll
uh we'll talk all about those things
before we get started head over to
timcast.com click that join us button to
become a member and support our work
directly as a member you'll get access
to exclusive segments from the timcast
IRL podcast live Monday through Thursday
just about 10 10 p.m after we wrap up
the live show we then broadcast a Live
members only show to the front page of
the website you click the little button
boom you're there and then it is
archived for you to watch whatever you
want
we also have the Discord rolling out
very soon with the VIP chat call-in
function and the special members only
elite club where you can hang out with
actual timcast staff crew and reporters
in our super special timcast club that
sounds pretty fun so if you want to
support our work that's how you do it we
are a member driven company so we rely
almost entirely on you guys members to
fund all of this and we really do
appreciate it so don't forget to also
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and a whole lot more is Angela
McArdle hey there thanks for having me
back absolutely who are you I am the
chair of the national libertarian party
and one of the organizers of the recent
Rage Against the war machine rally Ah
that's cool that's cool yeah we had uh
we had a big conversation about that
that's pretty great and everybody likes
Libertarians except for Libertarians
that's right we hate them that's right
well thanks for hanging out this should
be fun we also got Hannah Claire hanging
out hi I'm Hannah Claire brimwell I'm a
writer for timcast.com and I am Ian
cross and also considering that God may
be permeating through all of us at the
same time individually and collectively
in all seriousness seriousness though I
do find it weird that there seems to be
some kind of emotional Spectrum I notice
among people where I'll hear I'll hear
someone on social media say that like
they're depressed and then I'll hear the
same thing from like 15 other people all
at once like why are you all feeling the
same way I had a message from one of my
developers and he was saying his wife's
like a a I don't know like a prophet or
something she was like there's something
weird with the magnetic fields right now
if you're feeling down the last two
weeks something's going on you know they
say Mercury goes in a retrograde that
might have something to do with emotions
but I we don't have the tools to
calculate it yet it could it could also
be everybody reading the same garbage
social media upsetting depressing news I
don't know though because like there was
a period where everyone had the exact
same cough despite not being around each
other
like it was weird all like all of a
sudden on the same week everybody was
like I got this cough going on and I'm
like how come I'm hearing that from like
50 different people now I get it viruses
go around real quick or whatever but
some of these people didn't know each
other you know yeah I'll be careful how
I phrase it because of where we're
streaming to but if you want to go down
a rabbit hole in health you can look
into German new medicine which is a very
different view of germ Theory and and uh
fire virology and and the whole thing
with health really interesting yeah
terrain theory is work since it's
Synergy an opposite to germ Theory the
idea that germs float through the air
and land on you and duplicate his germ
Theory the idea that your terrain your
body itself if it's in a bad condition
the germs are there no matter what if
you're if your body's in a bad terrain
then it's gonna get sick and if it's in
a healthy terrain it can fight at all
the germs are there no matter what's
like all germs and all diseases are
everywhere all at once yeah exactly okay
so well we'll we'll save it for the show
but let's we'll start with the search oh
yeah and I am search.com the the angle
is wide today we're just going to leave
it that way sweet
all right well uh let's jump into the
first story it's really hard for me to
care about this to be completely honest
but apparently like everybody's tweeting
about it I know world war three is
trending Haley Biden revealed his new
Biden family member who got China cash
and I'm just like I don't care I don't
know man there's nothing that the Biden
family could be revealed to be doing at
this point which is going to make me go
oh egat I can't believe that happened
you know like I already think Joe
Biden's a pedophile you know that's my
personal opinion I mean but I'm pretty
sure his son Hunter calls him that pedo
Peter whatever so like the fact that
Biden's was his daughter Biden Hunter
Biden's sister-in-law turned former
lover was was subpoenaed uh had revealed
in subpoenaed bank records that she had
received Chinese cash in 2017. I'm just
like
they took more money from a from a place
they weren't supposed to take money from
with no consequences I mean is there
ever going to be any shocking there's no
reason to care about it because nothing
will happen I mean of course you should
be outraged but do we expect anyone to
be prosecuted for this no really Biden
family fatigue right on all of it like
even so it's it's uh with the the Polish
stuff I don't want to get into too much
of the Ukraine war because we're talking
about bidens but just as an aside
we were talking about the Downing of the
U.S drone and then I can't remember who
said it but they were like this will be
used as a pretext to send Jets to
Ukraine and it's like oh sure and like a
day later it literally happens we were
talking with Steve Bannon last week and
he's like guys come Monday they're going
to tell you to bail out this Bank say no
literally the next morning they're like
we're bailing out the bank and so it's
just like did the system break like is
it just done we've all seen this film
before yeah like oh it's gonna happen
it's it's and not just that but like the
system has shattered to the point where
people are just doing whatever they feel
like doing regardless of the
consequences yeah the power it's
starting to become more apparent that
power is what controls Society really I
mean love and caring and all that crap
it's important to build stable societies
but Power will do what power wants power
takes well maybe okay so I have an
optimistic view on this underwhelming
awful story maybe that means no war with
China everything's fine Biden family is
corrupt they're taking money from China
good relationship there we're all saved
no I think it means war with China
because uh what's gonna happen is the
bidens are corrup they're destroying the
economy their policy his policies are
trash he's he's not paying attention he
doesn't care he's completely incapable
even if he did care and the economy is
in free fall banks are collapsing Credit
Suisse is next and that collapse is
going to lead to a dramatic
transformation in this country one way
or the other and and the end result is
going to be the weakening of the country
and China taking an opportunity to
strike China's already told the United
States you are not negotiating from from
a position of power so anything that
happens at this point even Donald Trump
getting reelected that'll be an upswing
in my opinion but China's going to be
like uh oh Donald Trump's winning in the
polls we better strike now before he
wins
Taiwan okay right and then then
southeast Asia destabilizes or falls
under Chinese Communist influence we
lose that influence
I don't know how much I care about that
I I because I'm I'm at the point where
I'm kind of resigned to
Millennials and gen Z in this country
need to learn how to break rocks and
chop wood or something because they are
so entitled and lazy this country is
going to fall apart unless we actually
teach them how to I don't know look
they're they're they're they're doughy
doughy soy boys yeah our country is not
going to survive if it's being led by
doughy soy boys and it is I've been
watching a lot of carpentry videos it's
pretty sweet joint uh joinery joining
wood I mean you don't need Nails you
just cut the right angles and then set
it on itself and you create these Super
structurally Sound yeah sorry obviously
have you seen the Japanese ones they're
like weird and they like yeah stick
together and like lock and play cool
stuff there are all kinds of skills that
we used to have that we are forgetting
like I grew up in New England so there
are lots of stone walls well there used
to be people who could assemble stone
walls with no cement because they knew
how to identify the way the Rocks would
bounce and they stood for hundreds and
hundreds of years and I I knew a man who
this was his family trait like he
learned it from his grandfather and his
son was unfortunately addicted to
opioids was not in a position to learn
it and he died before he could pass it
on to his grandchild that's a whole
generation of people who built stone
walls and that skill is completely gone
like there are all kinds of Handy skills
that we just gave up because we believe
that we are completely internet laptop
bound generation I kind of think like
the doughy soy boys are going to result
in a very shattered tattered and
destroyed government which will create a
hard time which will result in strong
times like I don't think anyone needs to
make someone chop wood they're gonna
have to chop wood themselves because
otherwise they'll freeze to death it's
just the economy is failing you know
whether intentionally otherwise control
demolition call it what you want and
these doughy soy boys are going to go
out one day and be like where's the
heater and it's going to be like there
ain't one you best learn how to make a
wood stove and chop some wood and if
they can't then they'll simply freeze to
death doe is a generous description I
think I think do we I think they're not
all they're wet noodles wet noodles is
probably not appropriate yeah well some
of them are pretty doughy though too
much glutens too much your gluten that's
where you get the dough I don't know man
I'm seeing all these videos of people
being like I was misgendered and it's
just like that's so sad wow that's
disturbing China's gonna walk into the
United States and they're gonna they
already have but in the way they're
buying Farmland that's the way they're
walking say with Taiwan what they'll do
is they'll get them to vote it to be
China because they'll have spies there
that overthrow the government without
anyone knowing there won't be guns and
shot no one wants to fire guns really
I'm with you I don't think that China
and the us are going to war I think it's
actually indicative that it won't that
they've been trying to avoid World War
III which is why they're building a new
world order and they're happy to sell
out now whether or not peaceful slavery
is better than a war I don't know or I
mean if the United States dollar is no
longer the the unit of measurement that
the United that the whole world uses to
sort of you know measure itself against
if the dollar just goes away
and Chinese currency Rises to the top
that could be another thing maybe the
United States isn't going to go to war
with any other major world power maybe
we're just going to become irrelevant
yeah but as long as we have strong
borders you know I'm cool with it but if
we don't and then it becomes a unipolar
Chinese World Chinese Communist world uh
that would really really suck but as
long as we're not at War and there's not
troops on our ground in the United
States I don't really care like I don't
I don't believe in the United States
Global hegemony I'm not for that and if
that goes away if if our military bases
across the globe go away I'm okay with
that what happens 10 years after that
maybe nothing I mean how about others
China's already expanding into Africa
South America the Belton Road initiative
so if we go away China fills that vacuum
in their real real nasty people the
Chinese Communists sorry about one road
hasn't been very financially successful
though but yeah I'm not sure I'm not
sure that matters so much I mean a lot
of what the US does is predicated upon
just military might and the financial
stuff makes no sense they they're
they're going to infuse two trillion
dollars in loans to try and keep
liquidity in a collapsing system they'll
just do whatever well it doesn't last
forever you've got China right now uh
raping and torturing uyghur Muslims so
it's kind of like man I don't know if I
want to live in a world where they're
the dominant military superpower I'm not
saying that's happening anytime soon but
not that I like what the US does
overseas I think it's I think it's BS
for the most part but uh I'm also
willing to recognize that uh
the world's going to fall under the
control of of one group
at some point okay you know there's that
famous quote I think it was from uh was
it Nathaniel Rothschild or something and
he said globalism it's not a question of
of like how it will happen it's a
question of or if it's not a question of
if it will happen it's a question of
when and there's nothing anyone can do
to stop it or something like that you
want to look up the quote Yeah but it
hasn't happened yet but what people
misunderstood I think with that quote is
they they ascribe it to him as though
he's saying he is going to make it
happen and there is nothing anyone can
do to stop him when I think what he was
really saying was the natural trend of
power structures is to coalesce and the
world will fall under one governing
Authority it already has for the most
part the Swift payment system whether or
not that holds out for a total you know
uh executive Authority whether whether
we advance that point with the United
States in the west I'm not sure it could
be that China does it you know it could
be a Chinese Communist Global Authority
right now it's like
I think China's basically winning and
that's why we referred a lot of the
Davos group stuff in the world economic
Forum stuff as like CCP Chinese style
communism absolutely so it's like the US
is already losing this one
I can't find the who this quote I know
what you're talking about though was it
a Rothschild quote for sure pretty sure
um what do you see Angela like as a
better because I don't like the
military-industrial complex at all I
mean I but I I'm starting to gain
respect for what it has done which is
prevent World War III prevent communist
slavery like I'm allowed to say I'm
allowed to criticize Joe Biden cool with
that I mean I'm not convinced that we
have staved off China taking over the
United States I'm not convinced that
China actually has that in their sights
I don't I'm not convinced that that's in
their aim do I like Chinese communism no
I think communism is really horrendous
but I don't actually believe that
they're that they're dead set on trying
to take us over and that our giant
military power is the only thing that's
staving them off what do you think
China's objective is like why are they
making investments in other countries I
think that they want to become a
financial superpower I think that that's
really what they want and I think that
that's why would they want that if not
to like be in control well there's
different types of control right like if
you don't if you don't feel comfortable
with bloody World War III Warfare why
not just try to get as much Financial
control as possible and become the fine
Financial superpower I don't think that
it's the same as going out and
committing acts of mass murder I'm very
wary of a social credit system and
anything like that anything ESG social
credit anything that smacks of CCP but
I'm not so much worried about troops on
the ground over here or on Mexico you
know I feel like China invade should
become a new drinking game like every
time someone brings up China invades to
take a drink yeah it's a wonderful
Boogeyman you can always say those guys
that don't speak my language and they
can't disprove it because they don't
speak English no one will listen to them
anyway right you guys are saying that
China will not invade Taiwan I was
saying they would not invade the United
States oh well I mean that's very
different yes very oh they'll take
Taiwan two seconds I'm not I'm not I'm
not so sure about Taiwan Taiwan is very
very touch and go I think I think it
would be opportunistic I think that's
what's going to happen so there are some
so it depends on your your definition I
suppose there are some islands that are
part of Taiwan that are extremely close
to Mainland China which are already at
risk but they're like rocks so it's not
no one really cares but China's already
sent uh fighter jets into Taiwanese air
defense zones they've already done this
they've already blockaded the island
multiple times they're also building
Islands yeah they're they're building a
lot of military bases on Art of on our
artificial Islands so you know I don't
know we'll we'll see what happens I
guess my question is like what would be
better than the military-industrial
complex I feel like the liberal economic
order is the military-industrial complex
that order of Economics that
american-led
um and then it's evolving into this new
world order of some sort we're creating
a global economy a global system what
would be better that what's the
evolution that you see that would be
better than the military bases all over
Earth isolationism
I mean you know in a perfect world I'm
very very pro-free trade I think that
when when Goods don't cross borders
troops will free trade would be
definitely like what I think we should
have
um and and I think that you know
cryptocurrency and especially Bitcoin is
something that makes that possible so
that you can sort of bypass all of this
world economic Forum BS but uh if we
can't achieve that then I would just
want isolationism what isolationism I
think is is kind of accepted that that's
the cause the reason World War II kicked
off the way it kicked off because the
United States didn't want to get
involved until it was too late I think
that it would have gone just fine if the
United States had not gotten involved I
don't think the U.S intervention was
necessary in World War II really really
I mean it was the Russians and the
Germans versus France and Britain I
think they were already winning
the brilliant it was just the French
were taken over in two weeks and then
the British no not French no not the
French the British I think the British
were already winning the war when we got
in I think they were going to win it was
going to be
ugly
ugly Victory you know pretty brutal but
they were already bringing it home I
guess the U.S had funded them throughout
the war supplied weapons weapons so that
we I have a collection of old life
magazines that I bought an antique store
it's really cool to read about like it
was like three months before D-Day there
were reports that the U.S was staging
weapons in the UK for defensive purposes
and only now do we look back on history
and go oh they were planning on invading
and then this program so so there are
photos of all of this crazy U.S military
ordinance and materials in the UK like
we had been like whether if it was the
British soldiers that were weddings
because we were basically giving them
weapons yeah and keep in mind that Nazi
Germany was collapsing on the inside too
like they had totally burned through all
of their artillery their economy was
just absolutely just going up in smoke
it was it was a disaster over there so
they pushed really hard with German
Blitzkrieg strategy through everything
that they had at the as a war and then
it just ran out
so that was that was you know it's it's
not just like the United States came in
and just yay you know War over there was
so many things going on in that war like
I in an isolation an isolationist state
if we were would that just be me
National isolationism like where would a
couple questions where would the where
would it stop like how local would the
isolation become
uh I think it would be the federal
government just pulling out of as many
things internationally as possible and
then what if foreign countries start
polluting the air or like destroying the
ecosystem and then we're like hey guys
stop and they're like nah well I mean
they already are but we have bases kind
of like with nukes pointed at them and
you're like you're gonna stay in the
Paris Accord you're gonna do these
things that's like not this G yeah not
that it's a winning strategy but there's
like a deterrent to completely
annihilating your environment for profit
I don't know if that's a really like a
big concern that everyone has I think
right now developing countries are
polluting so that they can catch up with
the rest of the first world and and
maybe that's okay China is definitely
heavy on pollution I don't know that
they care of that that much what about
space space colonization if we're
isolationists and not involved in
China's colonization of mars or or if we
weren't doing it together where take it
to the moon like just you don't think
that would result in war if yeah that'll
definitely result in war explain it
again if we're not doing it together
let's not even go that far and say
Antarctica
should the U.S have territory Antarctica
cares the research scientists in
Antarctica
but why do we care about what they care
about it's Antarctica it's a chunk of
ice for now but by that logic you're
saying that none of what the United
States does matters outside of the
United States not very much so like
scientific research done outside of this
country is irrelevant
I don't think it's irrelevant but I
don't think it's worth going to war over
so then like what what's what's your
view of a functioning country then I
mean Antarctica I think is an
interesting question for Libertarians in
this regard because there there's
limited claims it's like everybody has a
sliver of it yeah and there's extremely
important research being done there
particularly drilling into the ice and
then tracking the state of the planet
over the past ten thousand years or
whatever and the you know fossil records
and things like that is going to grant
us a tremendous amount of information
which can probably be applied to
evolutionary biology which could
potentially be applied to genetics or
who knows what so we should just say no
we should give we should ignore all
potential new territories to foreign
countries
I would not go to war over Antarctica
that's how I would draw the line what if
there's like a new material discovered
on the moon that will allow China to
make a devastating new weapon
and we are there and we have a base
and like should we just abandon the base
and be like we don't want to we don't
want to get into a conflict with China
because they're interested in the space
well that's pretty far out there I mean
that's why I say it starts to go on the
moon what event what if China starts
making advancements in Antarctica
pressing them pressing into the U.S
borders should we Retreat because we
don't go to war
I think it really depends it's a
cost-benefit analysis and sometimes you
do have to seed ground that's that's
what I'm kind of arguing and advocating
for in the Ukraine Russia conflict
I mean the difference with Ukraine is
that it's it's useless to us it's a NATO
NATO wants this territory to expand they
want to expand their influence Russia
doesn't want to give up control of of a
border of a land bridge to one of its
only warm water I think it's only warm
water port in the Black Sea so they're
saying no NATO has no real interest in
it other than there's pipelines running
through it and they want to get energy
from you know the cutter turkey pipeline
up into Europe to lower the cost of gas
but that's an economic thing based on
gas and the United States and NATO are
unwilling to give that up to Russia
despite the fact that Russia had it in
the first place so in this instance it's
the U.S pushing on Russia to take from
them it's an inversion to the analogy of
sure of Antarctica so it's interesting
uh what about diplomacy because that's
something that's been really missing in
the Ukraine Russia conflict and I think
that diplomacy is something that the
United States should always employ no
matter what the conflict is the U.S and
the West tried diplomacy with Syria and
Syria said no
well can you expand on that a little bit
because there was a lot going on the
west Western forces wanted a pipeline
running through Syria turkey into Europe
to offset the gas prom gas Monopoly
Syria said no this would upset our Ally
Russia
well I think that we have not been
treating Russia with a with a lot of
respect and we have to respect that
Syria has a relationship with them
sometimes I think Russia should
surrender because going to war with the
United States is not worth it to defend
territory it's not part of Russia in
which Con in which respect Syria and
Ukraine I would love if they did yeah
they should have let the U.S just take
all that land
well why not
I mean it's none of our business right
ultimately I would think we should not
be involved in any of those conflicts
well it's not Russia so why is it
Russia's business
it's not our business to to police the
world so if we're in Antarctica minding
our own business and China starts
expanding we should Retreat because it's
none of our business I think the first
thing we should do is try to engage in
diplomacy and see what's going on there
and then when that fails we should
Retreat because none of our business
potentially so when it came to building
a pipeline through Syria Russia should
have said Syria let the United States do
whatever they want because going to war
is not worth it give them the pipeline
when it came to Ukraine Russia should
have said no no diplomacy has failed but
war is worse so we should we should
Retreat and give our border states to to
Nato in the west because it's not worth
going to war over I think our position
should always be diplomacy I don't think
that we can always sure in a perfect
world everyone should be diplomatic but
we can only be accountable for our own
actions right I guess I guess my issue
is
Russia has there's I think what like
Latvia and Estonia are on the border and
NATO absorbs them and now they've got
NATO on their border which was like they
were treated saying that we wouldn't do
this and it ends up happening anyway
Ukraine is on their border and they're
they are selling guests legitimately
through gas prom and other natural gas
companies through a pipeline into Europe
the United States doesn't like that
Russia makes money off this to this
degree and they don't like how much they
charge for it so the United States goes
to Syria and says we want to run a
pipeline through your country Syria says
no diplomacy fails the U.S decides to
destabilize Syria in a matter of
speaking they say Assad is gassing his
own people and he's a bad guy and sure
probably I don't know but but either way
it's so darn convenient for the U.S that
Syria destabilizes it's so darn
convenient for the U.S that Ukraine
destabilizes and then Russia takes a
land bridge in the Eastern portion into
Crimea where it enacts annexes Crimea
because it has a warm water Port there
the argument is Russia should let us do
whatever we want because we are not in
Russia we are in other countries no one
should stand in our way when the United
States does whatever it wants because
Russia is not Ukraine because Syria is
not Russia Russia should not have gotten
involved at all and that also means if
Russia sends military forces into Mexico
and weapons and starts building military
bases and sending weapons there we
should be totally okay with it and let
them do whatever they want because
Mexico is not the United States so it
sounds to me from all of this that the
United States needs to scale back its
military dramatically and maybe we don't
deserve to have a little bit of land in
Antarctica since we're taking it from
everywhere else across well then Russia
doesn't deserve to have it either but
why are they taking it who's gonna who's
gonna stop them from doing it Welcome to
The Human Condition I mean right and so
the the issue at hand is there is no
simple answer where the United States is
the bad guy every country is doing the
exact same thing
maybe this is like an enpoint coming
back to Power in the United States has
the most military power and there is a
little bit of an imbalance right now
they may have I'm not so sure that's the
case anymore the United States economy
is is is
in the gutter I mean it's not just the
United States it's NATO and it is a
massive military power
but there's also strengths and
weaknesses so technologically in terms
of air superiority I think the U.S is
you know typically heralded as the most
powerful in terms of aircraft carriers a
lot of things but China is the largest
standing ground army yes I think North
Korea has a crap ton of ground troops as
well and the important thing that people
need to realize is a fighter jet can't
occupy a street corner so while we may
have the capability to wipe out a whole
country with a barrage of mervs nuclear
warheads or you know bombard a city with
a fighter jet when it comes to actually
controlling territory we are not the
most powerful in terms of being able to
do that we would need a combined Force
to actually try and do it and if you
look at Afghanistan and Iraq not so easy
for us to pull off or especially Vietnam
so anyway long story short we do have a
lot of power and the United States does
do a lot of things we don't like the
issue is there's no simple answer in if
the if if the argument is we shouldn't
be doing it because none of our business
the same argument applies to any other
country China Russia or otherwise and no
one stopping them from doing it it's
basically I look at it like water
flowing downhill sure you might be like
we should try and stop that water
flowing downhills like dude it's water
flowing downhill you know what I mean we
want to prevent War for sure I don't
know how how you go about doing that
when all of these forces have to collide
with each other
I certainly think what the US is doing
in many ways is complete BS and we
should not be in Ukraine because we are
basically sending our interests into a
border country with Russia and of course
Russia's pissed and then we and now
they're who was it uh on TV said uh I
think it was Kamala Harris she was on
Colbert and she was like Vladimir
Putin's committing crimes against
humanity and everyone starts clapping
and cheering and I'm like this these
goons clapping I don't even know what
they're talking about Vladimir Putin's
certainly not a good dude to the
imagination but it's like the US is
either right it's a bunch of crackpot
War mongers fighting for power and
control and it's all basically the same
crap as far as I'm concerned yeah I mean
we need to get out of entangling
alliances and it is incredibly entangled
right now and try to engage in diplomacy
um and it's unfortunate that the people
in positions of Power are not inclined
to do so because they they generate
Financial wealth based on all these
tragedies happening across the globe I
think the big problem is
Donald Trump's a strong guy he's a
strong man quite literally that's what
they call him and he was working towards
peace with say North Korea and South
Korea he signed the Abraham Accords
there was a lot that he was doing to try
and simmer things down but from a
position of strength Joe Biden is
corrupt and I don't think actually cares
about anything other than
the hard numbers yeah which is why we're
reading a story about his families
getting money from China I didn't care
about China he just wants money for
himself and his family that is going to
lead to war that is going to lead to the
conflict and the downfall because that
is what ends up providing massive
funding to the military-industrial
complex a corrupt family saying
something like look I don't care if we
blow up a hundred thousand civilians how
much do I get in Kickbacks and then all
of a sudden 10 for the big guy so his
kids get paid then he gets a cut of the
salary and then the world Falls to crap
that seems to be what the Biden family's
been all about for the past decade or
you know several decades honestly and
Donald Trump was like let's have peace
defend our borders bring manufacturing
back and I'm like all of those are good
things
but when you have a system of neoliberal
crony capitalism
then you're going to end up with a
corporate press that wants to make money
they will do whatever they have to do to
make money and that means they'll Pony
up for any intelligence agency that
wants to maintain maintain power they'll
say whatever the advertisers want them
to say they'll push whatever narrative
is generating money for them they won't
push back against politicians see the
thing is these networks they want Pac
money they when it comes election season
oh boy you're going to get paid so if
you're NBC for instance and you keep
ragging telling the truth about the
Biden family well all of a sudden the
Biden packs aren't buying ads anymore I
mean that's tens of billions of dollars
you might lose over the course of a few
election Cycles your best bet is to shut
your mouth say nothing Donald Trump
didn't spend nearly as much money as
Hillary Clinton did and that's part of
the reason why we see so many TV
channels ragging on Trump he doesn't buy
from them he doesn't he doesn't give
them money so they don't care Hillary
Clinton's people were spending tons of
money on the media and they're like we
don't want to lose these customers
they're paying the bills so this is a
big problem anyway long story short
that's why Independent Media is so
important you know my problem with
isolationism I keep thinking about World
War II like the way that the French saw
Hitler expanding his growing his
military rapidly and then with the eyes
and the East and the sudate and land and
stuff but the French were just like
we're not going to stop them we're we're
Live and Let Live we'll use diplomacy
Hitler was like yeah we're great friends
yeah we're just gonna build some more
tanks we're great friends violating
treaties building tanks and the French
are like we're just gonna have a strong
defense a defense offensive border wall
and the Germans just plowed through it
the the Arden Forest they were like they
built the majino line this huge
defensive trench line series of trenches
and they're like no nothing can get
through this but there's this thick
dense forested area called the Arden
forest and the Germans took these new
technological things these tanks these
Panzer tanks never seen before just
plowed through the forest into France
into Paris like in a week so if you just
sit there and wait and just hope that
he's gonna go say what he's going to do
like they're going to find a technology
that can breach your defenses that's my
fear of isolationism well it's
definitely not preferable to me over
free trade and diplomacy and and you
know positive international relations
but I prefer it over globalism for sure
globalism I think I think globalism is
inevitable and it's because power
coalesces no matter what I'm not saying
that Global communism is inevitable but
trade lines will inevitably result in
international agreements which will
eventually result in international law
enforcement which which will ultimately
result in international courts which
will ultimately result in international
legislative bodies and then you have
globalism we basically have it now I
just wanna I want the ability to be able
to opt out of globalism I don't want
Global rule to be something that
everyone is subject to does that make
sense it's governance yeah Global
governance but I think no matter what
happens it it will be there well I mean
you already exists I mean look you you
can go and live in the woods and for the
most part you're fine but if you want to
be in this system the system is
increasingly coalescing around itself
like it's it's it's forming a hard shell
yeah yeah if you're in it you're in it
well I mean it used to be that if you
committed a serious crime let's go back
to the 1800s if you like were a train
like a bandito and you robbed a train
and killed some guy you could ride off a
thousand miles west change your name and
nobody would have any idea that'd be the
end of it you'd you'd go from being John
Smith to Jack Williams and people would
be like oh how do you back I'm just you
know coming up and here's the work that
I did and I'm looking for a job and
that's it you can't do that today if
you're in the United States and you
commit a crime you go to a foreign
country they're going to find you and
they're going to depending on that if
they have an extradition treaty it is
all increasingly becoming one small
world where you're gonna look you know
you want you want you want to know the
evidence of globalism already happening
every single City I've gone to the
tourist districts have the exact same
stores sure they've got Dolce they've
got uh whatever they got Starbucks
McDonald's Hard Rock Cafe bubble gum
shrimp one of the most brutal things
ever was when I went to the Bahamas I
was I think is that where NASA yeah and
uh I was like oh this is gonna be really
cool it's like it's like a different
country basically and you get off the
boat and I walk in and I'm like am I in
Times Square like it's the same thing
it's identical and then you walk in
here's the best part I remember when I
started traveling the world for for vice
and I'm like oh man what do I have to do
anything special for the currency and
they're like no and I'm like we no no
you have a credit card right yeah it's
it's hard to any country you go to you
swipe your Visa good to go I feel like
you'd need multiple countries to agree
to be isolationists like outside of the
US I'm not sure which countries could
successfully pull off being truly
isolationist like maybe Australia but
really everyone else is so linked I mean
I think of European countries that need
each other to traffic oil or to traffic
food I mean wouldn't you need a
coalition of countries saying we're just
gonna stick to ourselves otherwise you
make yourself incredibly vulnerable I
mean the Donald Trump's kind of America
First policy sounds it sounds kind of a
isolationist right bringing
manufacturing back not engage but
outside the US who else could pull that
off that's a good question I bet there
are countries that do it they're just
not uh they don't have they're not as
cozy and comfortable as we are and I
don't think Americans are willing to
give that up to be honest well Tim
thinks we should all be in the forest
chopping trees right and building walls
I think that
Millennials and gen Z are doe soy boys
for the most part and that's why they're
entitled that's why they cry and
complain that's why they vote for
ridiculous policy that makes no sense
that's why California is is now
proposing reparations despite the fact
California is a free state and has
always been a free state it was admitted
as a free state and there and and the
best part is you only have to identify
as black you don't have to actually be
it's crazy isn't it so Rachel dolezal so
Rachel dolezal only she would qualify if
she lived there if she lived there okay
so if Rachel dolezal lived in San
Francisco for 13 years and had a family
member that was incarcerated due to the
War on Drugs she would qualify for the
five million dollars
none of it makes any sense these people
need to experience a cold winter where
someone comes in and says it's time to
chop wood or we freeze to death and then
they can realize what a good day of hard
work really means and why you should not
steal from other people Wilderness
Survival Camp
well I don't know all I'm saying is
these are people who are voting to steal
from people they're saying the
reparations are going to cost six
hundred thousand dollars per per family
in San Francisco to cover the cost of
the reparations so what they're doing is
they're saying if you identify as black
not if you are
and you're over 18. you then have to
qualify for two of eight different
criteria one of which is you're the
descendant of somebody who was enslaved
in the United States despite the fact
that California's a free state one of
them is have a descendant or yourself be
incarcerated due to the War on Drugs
which is nebulous what does that even
mean well I went to jail for marijuana
so they're still putting people away for
for using drugs in California well
that's that's that's that's one uh one
box checked and then if uh so what was
it what was the other one you have to uh
be incarcerated or have a family member
who's incarcerated and then what was the
other one I just said I lived in San
Francisco for a certain amount of time
15 years so you could go you could
intentionally get arrested for on a drug
charge go serve a little bit of time get
out and be like five million dollars yes
amazing if you live in sap for for at
least 13 years and you identify identify
as black for at least 10 years and are
over 18.
then yeah that is a get rich that is a
get rich scheme well I don't know if
they're actually going to do it but I
don't it it doesn't I hope they do I
absolutely since I've moved out I'm kind
of like burn it all down I feel very
bitter about what they did to California
I'm like go ahead and burn
we moved in September we moved to Austin
Texas what city were you in uh L.A uh
briefly for a little bit of time in
Newport Beach which is a really nice
area but same tax rates you know
everything else and it was creeping in
this is why oh what's last thing you
said everything else about California
was creeping in you know these
reparations you might think it's going
to repair something which is what the
word reparation is supposed to entail
but it's going to create many more
problems if you take six hundred
thousand dollars from one family and
then give it to another family the
government does that you don't think
that's going to create animosity between
the people that got 600 000 taken
especially when you I mean it's going to
bankrupt the city no matter what even if
you take money away from someone else so
you are hurting everyone who's there and
giving wealth to some people just to
create a city where it's chaos I mean it
doesn't make any sense all right so I
got it right here here's here's the list
you must be an individual who has
identified as black or African-American
on public documents for at least 10
years you must be at least 18 years or
older then you must also meet two of
these eight criteria and be able to
prove it born in San Francisco between
1940 and 96 and have proof of residency
for at least 13 years migrated to SF
between 1949-96 and have proof of
residency for at least 13 years
personally or the direct descendant of
someone incarcerated by the failed War
on Drugs record of attendance in San
Francisco public schools during the time
of the consent decree
to complete desegregation within the
school system descendant of someone
enslaved through U.S Channel slavery
before 1865. displaced or the direct
descendant of someone displaced listed
or the direct descendant of a
certificate of preference holder or
member of a Mart oh this one's great
member of an historically marginalized
group that experienced lending
discrimination in San Francisco between
1937 and 1968 or subsequently
experienced Landing discrimination in
the formerly redlined San Francisco
communities between 1968 and 2008.
basically it's extremely easy to qualify
for the reparations program so let's
break it down
Rachel dolezal
if she identifies as black does that
mean she is a member of a marginalized
group
if the first criteria is only
identification and not actual genetic
testing she would also qualify for being
a member of a marginalized group then
because she identifies as such
she would then only need to live in San
Francisco before 1996.
so how many people live down there who
are like Rachel de luzov never been
found out who are going to get paid even
though they're like white as white can
be oh there's going to be so many oh
that's going to be a long line but it
sounds like if you identify if you're a
white person that identifies as black
that doesn't get you to become a member
of a marginalized Community which if
you're assuming it's a black community
so you only identify as it you're not
actually it so it's different no no no
no no hold on this is why this is why
you're wrong if you look at the criteria
it's as an individual who is identified
as black African-American on public
documents for at least 10 years the main
criteria that you have to have is that
you have to be able oh okay and if that
is their hard-line standard then I
certainly believe the member of a
historically marginalized group is a
lower standard or or the same or the
same standard in which case if their
argument is you have to identify as
black I really doubt they would change
their view on what it means to be a
member for a different part of the same
crisis they're trying to lock out people
that are black that identify as white I
think that's the what that first by
letting in people who are white to
identify as black and I'm trying to keep
them right now but I think Rachel
dolezal as a female could claim she's
part of a marginalized group oh yeah
boom there you go well I mean oh and
absolutely women explaining
discrimination no question left-handed
people
hold on women couldn't get credit cards
yeah San Francisco recognizes women or
sex discrimination as you know oh boom
so Rachel dolezal she is a member of
historically marginalized group she's
over 18 she identifies as black so what
else does she need she just needs to
have lived in San Francisco and she
would qualify for reparations dude that
is fantastic I hope they give this money
out seriously it doesn't have like an
income or a net worth criteria you can
no 45 million bucks and a one dollar
house how many people do you think
qualify who live in cities man it's
gonna be funny because it's going to be
like half the city yeah it's amazing
people are going to be like first of all
like almost every woman qualifies
like that's just it it's gonna be worse
than a bank run there's Wild
but I guess you have to you have to
identify on public documents that you're
black
so that's a big that's a big one because
you couldn't have foreseen this I mean
maybe some people could it's pretty
insulting to the black community for
people who are actual descendants well
we all know Rachel those all but I
wonder how many people have been
claiming they're black in San Francisco
for years right like she's the one who
got caught but that doesn't mean she is
the only person in America who's done
this like I think there will be so many
people yeah
he has never confirmed it the jury's out
on that one I don't know I can't I mean
he looks white and then there was that
document the police arrest report that
called them white I'm pretty sure my
buddy's a black albino talked about him
on the Victor Varnado shot what's up
Victor uh yeah albino dude he's white as
me but he's black dude apparently
whatever that means but his ancestry is
like African I believe it's wild and
there's I don't remember what what
country but there's a nation in Africa
that has the highest rate of albinism in
the world it's like just a genetic they
used to think they were witches and they
would like burn them at the stage even
now it's incredibly dangerous because
there's all kinds of like yeah of uh I
don't know what what to call it but like
lore about you know the the bones or
flesh of uh people who have albinism
wow
I hope they do the reparations you do
yeah because it'll be really funny to
watch from afar to see all the white
liberals be like the roads aren't paved
yeah and there's poop everywhere and
then they go to the City Hall meetings
and they're like why isn't this getting
done and they're going to be like
because we spent five trillion dollars
in taxpayer money to give people five
million dollars what did you think San
Francisco needs to be punished that
place needs to be punished God said he'd
never flood the Earth let's let's send
this reparations Bill instead you know
we should be careful about praying for
punishment to the city because there
might be an earthquake that thing's been
terrorized by the San Andreas fault line
let's not do that let's just make it uh
absurdity all right there are as of 2021
000 people in San Francisco the Metro
itself is bigger five percent of that uh
population is black so giving us around
40 000 or so people so uh simply put
forty thousand times five million five
million
let's do some quick uh quick math there
and uh oh man that's a lot of zeros so
uh what is that 20 trillion what is that
20 trillion where is this number
I think it's uh I think it's is that 20
trillion dollars that sounds fun so let
me see it's it's commas up in that
200 trillion 200 trillion 200 billion
I think it's 200 trillion
trillion
everyone in the chat's gonna be like
dude it's 200 trillion they're doing the
math 200 trillion dollars that's not
even in existence just a regular number
okay to be fair not every single black
person in that city is gonna qualify
right no no because you have to be
overrated but when you add in all of the
other people who are going to lie so
that they do qualify
could be even more than forty thousand I
mean the other part is like what if they
roll this out realize they can't you
know comply with the measures they put
out they have to say wait we're going
back to the drawing board and making
stricter regulations like then no no
it's 200 billion then the people who
thought they were going to get this
payout are going to be livid are you
sure yep I'm talking 200 trillion as
well it's right you said it was no it's
200 degrees right I'm sorry 5 million
times forty thousand two hundred billion
40 000 times 5 million 200 billion
dollars no no no that's that's trillion
no I'm pretty sure it's
200 billion dollars I'm intentionally
not looking 200 billion oh yeah you're
right 200 billion that's weird
god what the
well let's do let's do something else uh
100 billion that's not that much total
total budget for San Francisco
nice total SF budget billion
2022. it's uh 14 billion they're also
going to give homes out for one dollar
I would like everybody listening
to do the right thing
and advocate for San Francisco to
implement this policy make it happen
what if it works then great it's good
for them why would I be mad because then
they'll do it to your city no no wait
wait what but if it works okay all of a
sudden everyone's holding hands and
singing songs Under rainbows I'd be like
well I'll be damned yeah it worked it'll
be fine problem solved but it's not
going to work it's going to destroy San
Francisco and I'm here for it I'll get
the popcorn San Francisco's already
pretty shredded it's it's an awful place
there's poop everywhere it is look man
if they voted for it they deserve it the
first day I went to San Francisco I was
going to move there and I parked my car
and went to look at the apartment when I
came out my window was smashed and my
bag had been stolen with my laptop
everything lesson learned Man Dirty city
with a lot of desperate people yeah
that's so sad not so so hold on paying
four thousand dollars a month for a one
bedroom kidding me all right all right
let's say half those people are under
18. okay and half of the people who are
over 18 were not born there and don't
qualify so let's just say it's 50
billion okay
50 billion dollars is still you know
around what four times their their their
budget so let's talk about the houses as
well let's say they've got that's going
to be uh
what is that that's that's ten thousand
what's their homeless population
uh the homeless population so they're
they're giving away but yeah but it's
not that I mean somebody's got an
apartment's going to want a house too
sure so let's just let's just do the
math and say
half are under 18 and of the remaining
20 half qualify so you've got 10 000
people and then what we'll do is
um 10 000 houses
and the average what's the average cost
of a house in San Francisco you want to
Google that real quick
take guesses minus 1.2 million yeah look
it up average I feel like it's higher
it's got to be higher I feel like it's
maybe I'm gonna go 2.2 million yeah in
San Fran it's very it's very small
Jersey the average house cost in San
Francisco is around 350 000 no due to
the skyrocketing real estate and like
that I mean I'm getting houses but like
apartments and stuff that's from
fortune.com
um this is House cost 350 000 what for
your down payment
that's wild 1.2 million okay what the
Fortune 1.238 million San Francisco home
values down 10 percent Ian you are
spotting it is down 10 all right yeah so
I think I think you may be looking at
San Francisco Metro which is massive San
Francisco has it in and of itself is
1.23 1.35 million according to Red so
let's uh let's add that to the uh number
there
and it's another 12 billion oh so we're
looking at like I don't know about 60
billion dollars realistically yeah I'm
excited it would be good to give people
houses that want them because biggest
barrier entry a lot of times to get back
into society is getting a shower not
having access to clean water and a
shower if you can clean up easy to get a
job then you can get back on your feet
so it's like 350 000 people I want to
help people too like not to bankrupt the
entire city that's called projects and
they are usually not great places to
live if they're I think the Russians
were doing with Farmland they're like if
you want a homestead for a year you can
get what number would you come up with
they said it would cost the average
non-person of color in the city around
six hundred thousand dollars so I did
the the rough math there's 44.9 white in
in a city of 815 000 which is like 300
some odd thousand three hundred and
fifty thousand times six hundred
thousand is 210 billion
it all adds up six hundred thousand
dollars per uh per a non-person of color
in San Francisco uh I I seriously hope
they do this because these people voted
for it do Asian and Latino people pay
the same amount I don't know I bet they
introduced the scale eventually
or like immigrants if you're like I I
just got here why would I have to pay
this so I'm not a fan of race Wars and
this is um
if if they voted for this then they
deserve it they do if you vote they do
to get a new playground put in your
community you deserve it the problem
with representative government it's not
going to only charge the 600 000 to the
people who voted in favor of these
things right like people who voted
against it will also have to pay for it
yeah dude if you want to live in a city
where they're telling you that you are
an evil white supremacist and they're
taking your money and you're like okay I
guess well I'm not going to shed a tear
for you you got to move you got to move
well check this out check this out we
have I pulled up the demographics of San
Francisco 2020 it was 873 965 and then
2021 was 815 000 a drop of six percent
take a look at that what was the six
percent drop in what was it six percent
drop in population from 2020 to 2021.
people left yeah who wants to be there
that is a big drop I mean that's like
the last 10 years of growth lost in one
year smart people should migrate uh
you're right it absolutely is around 10
years of growth lost in one year wow and
where did they go well Arizona yeah well
someone said well some went to Florida
the more conservative leaning ones but a
lot of them went to Arizona and turned
Arizona blue oh wait yeah no that's five
Decades of growth lost people who don't
learn that no no no no no no that's
that's look in 2010 it was 805 and 2020
was 873 and 2021 was 8 15. okay so it's
not five decades right uh yeah if you go
back five decades you're looking at 740
000. so you know the city hasn't hasn't
really grown that much you know what it
is
they're zombies yeah the left is a
zombie horde it's a zombie ideology
that's what's happening right now and
when they spread
they bring that to government so that's
why Arizona is turning blue because
people are fleeing California because
they're zombies it's so sad a lot of my
liberal friends have left California
moved to Arizona and they are voting and
behaving in the exact same ways when
they lived in California how do you feel
like sorry I was to say if as a person
who fled California for a red State like
do you feel like you get a bad rap
because you also left California well I
have a loophole because I grew up in
Texas oh okay never mind I moved to
California when I was a teenager with my
family so when people ask me where I'm
from I'm like Longview Texas you're like
I'm going back home yep yep failed
experiment how do you fortify
libertarianism against mob rule
guns she's just you just threaten people
no I mean I'm just oversimplifying it I
mean give me give me like a scenario you
mean against mob rule I mean a
well-armed society is a polite Society
like that's not hyperbolic there's 10
000 of us all armed
six thousand five thousand and ten of
them wanna redirect the Waterway to
their side of the city
I mean you got to work that out
there's not a lot of scenarios where we
in the modern present day era we've just
straight up go to war over a river we
usually have negotiations and policies
and you know dealing with things like
that but the reality is we don't live in
a Libertarian Society right now and if
we were in a Libertarian Society you're
going to be much less likely to to have
people just going and engaging in mob
Rule and taking over waterways
let's jump to this you wanna one more
thing uh no no let's go let's jump to
this next story I've been uh dying to
talk about this one and because it's a
slow news day I get to I have this tweet
from Elon Musk no doubt replying to me
saying Temple's right thank you uh Elon
Musk responded to me saying some truth
to this so some agreement there when I
defined wokeness and here we have this
tweet of uh Elon Musk I'm sorry I'm just
making fun of Luke gradkowski because
when he was when he was on the show and
Elon followed him he started walking
around the house making sure everybody
knew that Elon started following him and
he was just walking around with his
close personal friend he was smiling and
he was like hey uh did you guys hear and
like what's happened he's like oh Elon
followed me and everyone's like okay
Luke so that's what happens we start
working out I hope Luke's listening
here's the tweet I said understanding
what woke is is simple I like how it
says is
it is the modern left liberal culture
created by algorithms on social media it
is characterized by cult-like adherence
to rapidly changing ideological
foundations rooted in various leftist
theories it is social zombism that's it
that's it everybody hyper focuses on one
element or one aspect of the modern
culture of the left I disagree with
completely ignorant of the fact that
those of us and there are many many
others who have been doing this long
than I have those of us who have been
tracking the culture War for a long time
have seen so many different forms of
whatever wokeness is you begin to
realize after the first few years there
is no ideology first it was feminism
then it was intersectional feminism then
it was intersectionality it was feminism
intersectional feminism
intersectionality as a whole which
started including a bunch of other
components to it then it became critical
theory critical race Theory critical
gender Theory and ultimately wokeness
all it means simply put it's the modern
left liberal culture that has been
formed by social media algorithms it is
the political equivalent to a teenage
girl crying because people won't like
her Instagram photo of her butt that's
what it is these people go on social
media their world is politics and they
want to get as many likes as possible
end of story I have some questions about
your definition yeah sure let me give
you an example real quick so you can
understand here's a tweet from genk
yuger he says I don't even know if quote
Equity is a real thing that anyone
outside of 12 leftists and the entire
right wing believe is real the
overwhelming majority of progressives
agree with Bernie Sanders and me that
equality of opportunity is the right
standard well hold on there mister how
can Joe Biden have a national Equity
initiative how can every University be
talking about diversity equity and
inclusion and then all of a sudden
Bernie Sanders and The Young Turks are
like nobody even thinks Equity is a real
thing that is the perfect example of
exactly what I'm saying there is no
ideology it is whatever the thought
leaders say on a whim so when Bernie
Sanders goes on Bill Maher and says I
think we want equality of opportunity
then all of a sudden they all start
going yup yup yup I've always been for
this
you could if you got Bernie Sanders to
come out and advocate for laissez-faire
capitalism they would all of a sudden be
like we've always been in favor of
capitalism we're not socialists that is
what wokeness is
fire away Ian I have a bunch of
questions too I saw you you said uh it
is the modern left liberal culture you
have left slash liberal as if it's one
thing so how do you like what's what is
this left thing mean exactly left
liberal is that the same exact thing uh
because that's a definition I want in
order to understand your definition is
it's left liberal is a tribal reference
that's why it's left liberal because the
the political left is characterized by
this group this this how would I want
radical change not no they don't want
radical change
not even progressives because you if you
can be uh a neolib and be woke yeah you
can be a progressive and be woke you can
be a socialist it's just are you
adhering to the cult-like structure of
this the current thing of the of current
thing that's that's a that's a great way
to frame it do you adhere to current
thing yes or no if you do you're woke if
you don't you're not that's a real
simple way to put it so here's a
question I have
um I'm not disagreeing with your
interpretation of wokeness but I feel
like it must have started in fairly
recent history would you correlate it
rise of social media it is yeah and
that's that's factually proven
um we went over this years ago with uh
Zach Goldberg put up the Lexus Nexus
data showing the rise of certain
terminology appearing in newspapers
around the rise of social media and what
ends up happening is you get these
academics to a hammer everything looks
like a nail and they're like hey these
terms come from Academia oh man this
proves it and then people of course like
listening to academics so even people
who are anti-establishment will see some
Rogue academics and be like ah the
intellectual dark web they must be very
smart know what they're talking about
but they mostly don't I mean they do to
a certain degree with all due respect
but I had this conversation as I
mentioned numerous times with Peter
pagosian and James Lindsay years ago
where I said I I grew up on the internet
I watched all of these things happen I
certainly understand critical race
theories emergence Frankfurt School
marched to the institutions and all that
stuff but what they don't understand is
it could have been any ideology at all
any ideology but the social media
algorithms
favored these particular phrases for
money-making reasons that's why that's
why Libertarians founded it is said I am
told because I have friends who worked
for mike.com that the guys who started
were like Ron Paul Libertarians and when
mike.com was first started it was very
anti-anti police brutality very pro-run
Paul very pro-libertarian and then over
a few years it became totally leftist
and woke because it was just chasing the
algorithms the reason the algorithms
were made was not because it was a
conscious effort by infiltrators at
Facebook it was because advertisers said
here are no no words and that's just a
runaway train it happens to align with
one ideology it didn't come from that
ideology so the path of Silicon Valley
was really techno-libertarian to woke
yes so it's it's it's really simple if
you think about it an Advertiser like
Coke goes to Facebook and says you've
got you've got five posts okay one is
screaming to mercilessly beat white
supremacists one is screaming to
mercilessly beat Communists one is
screaming to Mercy beat white people or
whatever and they're like no one
complains when someone makes fun of
white people so we don't care about that
but that white supremacist stuff's got
to go and then everyone agrees like yeah
we really don't want that on the
platform
half the people agree the anti-white
stuff has to go so you start seeing that
this leads to a rise an inverse rise in
white nationalist ideology because all
of a sudden on social media they're
actively saying in their rules you're
allowed to insult white people Facebook
did this Facebook I think it was
Facebook forgive me if I'm wrong but
they said that you are allowed to
criticize groups if they are coming from
positions of power which resulted in a
whole bunch of insane posts and then all
of a sudden they got rid of it and then
a bunch of feminists who are saying kill
all men started getting banned and they
got angry about it saying we are allowed
to do this but but simply put
if a comedian makes about a white person
nobody cares comedian makes fun of a
black person people are going to have an
issue with it advertisers only care
about that it has nothing to do with
cultural Marxism it has to do with them
saying look we get a hundred complaints
when the comedian makes fun of black
people we get zero compliance and they
make fun of white people or we get
complaints from like seven people
conservatives don't care they don't
boycott they mind their own business and
everyone kind of Chuckles so we have no
problem with our ads appearing on that
stuff that weight causes the shift it is
not because the ideology took over it is
because
it is a hyper amplification of the fact
that people don't like racist things and
tolerate things that that are targeting
men or targeting white people
Etc this gives rise to intersectionality
which gives rise to all the other
disparate ideologies but it also
explains exactly why woke people
seemingly change their minds every day
as to what they really believe because
they don't believe anything so the terms
that uh ultimately gave us the
algorithms that we have now or in the
the terms of services that we have now
were directly correlated from basically
who was complaining the loudest like if
I saw something I didn't like and
identified it because you know I'm
female so I think that's offensive that
that sort of early intervention in uh
the social media Marketplace is what
directed this yes mostly it's basically
that you take some young person they're
bored no one knows them no one cares
about them and they want likes they will
find a way to get those likes one of
those ways is to post nudes or something
so young girls are posting scantily clad
images getting lots of likes and
followers it sure feels good when
everyone's following you I was at VidCon
on seven years ago and I remember seeing
these like little kids were talking to
each other and one kid goes you have 80
followers how like that's creepy yeah I
wonder where those kids are now all they
cared about was their follower account
some people find through politics now
because here's how I described it you
know like eight years ago
the intersectional feminists are
basically like white blood cells it's an
autoimmune disorder we all agree racism
is bad it is it is detrimental to a
functioning economy we need to find a
way to work together the example of this
is how we ultimately got the civil
rights movement and the story as I'm
told is Lyndon Johnson I think it was
Johnson had staff members who were black
and he needed his dog taken home and
they were like we can't and he's like
why not they're like because we can't
use any facilities anywhere we have a
dog with us we won't be able to do
anything and he was like what do you
mean like because of segregation we
can't even stop for gas or go to the
bathroom and he was like okay that's a
problem because I got to get stuff done
and I need your help so the the nature
of the economy leads people being like
this doesn't work
so naturally we all say these things are
bad
so when it comes to social media people
are trying to find ways to get clicks
and get likes well everyone agrees on
this one thing so then you get young
people saying if I say one if I say this
thing I'll get clicks police brutality
videos go viral but you add a component
of racism and it goes quadruple viral so
people start spamming the stuff to make
money and generate traffic and it
creates a self-fulfilling prophecy
creating young people built on this
ideology who are inundated with this
crackpot algorithmic garbage and that's
why their ideas make no sense are are
not coherent and it's a cult all they
want to do is say what they need to say
to fit in that's why jenkiewer comes out
and goes Bernie Sanders is Right
equality of opportunity the whole time
it's like my guy you were just out
talking about Equity like a year ago
what happened no Bernie Sanders said so
and he's got more status than he does so
you got to adhere to whatever the status
quo is I felt like before social media
it existed still but you didn't see it
they were like I remember 911 and
everybody was on board go get Saddam and
his weapons of mass destruction like the
message of the day was Saddam Hussein
bad everyone just put it put that
Ukraine flag in their bio and went with
it and like but no one knew how crazy it
was at the time because we didn't have
social media to see ourselves in action
and now you can obviously see people
falling into this narrative whether I
guess far left narrative you would call
it this is radical
like gave us an individual way to to
track the data right like I saw that you
posted in favor of this issue and you
got a lot of likes so that makes me
question whether or not I should
challenge you on it because it seems
like all of our mutual friends support
you and it also explains their tactics
the reason why they try shaming you and
doing these Brigade campaigns because
they're trying to use negative social
pressure to make you do what they want
or give give them what something you
have because they're looking for the
same thing but there does there does
seem to be some sort of
um you know Marxist or left cultural
element that is complementary to it
because that's what social media is
picking up and in three years it won't
be in three years it'll be something
different well that would be amazing and
refreshing well I mean look at what
jankugur is saying literally right now
quality of opportunity that's
classically limited it's definitely
become a little bit of an outlier and
like difficult too now I know this is
exactly what wokenessa is the fact that
Bernie Sanders didn't know what Equity
was this this is the perfect example
Bernie Sanders on Bill Maher he gets
talked about what it is he doesn't know
and then says uh I think uh I don't know
I we want equality of opportunity
because he didn't know what he was
talking about right then all of a sudden
they go I I I I I agree I've always
agreed with that it's like bro that's
not Marxism that's Classical liberalism
that's what we've been arguing for I
want to see that happen I mean if that
is if that's what's coming down floating
down the river
of of wokeness that would be fantastic
it will not change the fact that these
people are violent cultists wow so what
will end up happening is they'll say do
you agree with me or not in this
instance you'll be like well I do like
equality of opportunity and then they'll
slowly lower their crowbar and say okay
you're like me and then they'll go and
attack someone else they're zombies it's
social zombism they go from person to
person they infect you with their
ideology which is it's it's there's not
even an ideology they infect you with do
what we say or it will be painful for
you then the person says I'm just going
to do whatever I'm told otherwise it'll
be painful for me and they continue to
spread that's why zombies that's why
they go from California to Arizona and
everything keeps happening they flee
because of how bad it is but keep
bringing it with them it's zombism so is
there a chance that that what what
wokenesses will ever be something
positive will it ever be positive if
it's just cultural trends no current
thing racism is bad right yep fighting
against racism is a good thing yep these
people are operating under that premise
and it is nightmarish
so so they're always going to be
fighting against something they have to
hate something yep they have to be
against something and conversely many on
the right are exactly this and that's
why people can't define what woke is
it's a culture of hate is what it sounds
like every Everybody tries to Define
woke in some way and I'm surprised I see
so many people doing these long-winded
paragraphs about post-modernism and
intersectionality and all these things
and I'm like
these are probably people who only
recently started following this stuff
because I've been tracking this stuff
for for a while now and there are many
people have been following it longer
than I have
but I'm like
seven years ago I mean what was it seven
years ago when I did that video for
Sargon of akkad on his channel what we
defined as woke was dramatically
different
very very different it wasn't it was not
what it is today
I mean you you look at the rapid
transformation of you know saying like
kids shouldn't get sex changes which
then becomes kids aren't getting sex
changes which then becomes they get it
but it's rare why are you mad too it's
happening it's a good thing it's not
that the ideology is like they're trying
to take over it's that there isn't one
it just changes yeah I sense a dialectic
in in woke it's like a false adherence
to a dialectic whatever that's a simple
way to explain there's always this and
that in the idea of like the other
there's this like it was Saddam Hussein
in 2003 and now it's Vladimir Putin or
it's white people or it's the rich
people or whatever but like if you're
gonna fall into this Us and Them mindset
you're basically falling into a woke
pattern we got a super chat from uh
Katia says Tim it's simple the left
appeal to Authority the right
individually that's what what uh what's
woke don't overthink it that's a good
way to put it too the left is basically
do are you in with current thing or not
and the right is kind of like
you know I think for myself what's
really splitting everybody is the
internet has allowed for the zombies to
coalesce and for the individualists to
expand their knowledge base and and you
know yeah have a voice to them people
that can hold multiple truths at once
like think oh Vladimir Putin's a bad guy
and zielinski's a bad guy it's okay to
think that you don't have to pick a side
here or they're both good guys you don't
have to pick a side like here actually
Ukraine's a really good point
under what Marxist theory is the war in
Ukraine written about or supported
it there isn't it's simply put nothing
in these lettuce ID ideologies has
anything to do with Ukraine yet for some
reason these people are all pro-ukraine
war they are very much has nothing to do
with leftism in fact you could argue
that true leftist ideology opposes War
the idea of collectivism wouldn't exist
with interventionism or
interventionalism whatever to call it
this is good evidence
that these people don't actually adhere
to any kind of ideology they just do
what the machine says to do current
thing current thing current thing is
pro-ukraine so we're pro Ukraine no
matter what it means this is how you end
up with Hassan criticizing the
military-industrial complex and
supporting the war in Ukraine at the
same time so bizarre because there's no
ideology there it's just
look they're they're looking at the
system like
logic doesn't matter what matters is all
that you agree so if the left used to be
about the military industrial complex is
bad and that artifact remains but today
you have to Pro Ukraine they will say
both things are true at the same time
despite the fact that they can't be
does the relationship wokeness have with
social media and the internet mean that
someone could use it to steer wokeness
in a certain direction like if you got
something trending you could decide what
wokeness is going to support yep
absolutely I remember I was at a protest
for occupy for uh Trayvon Martin in New
York and they were going to march to One
Police Plaza Occupy Wall Street
activists showed up went to the front of
the March and then started Fanning
people in a different direction and
brought them to Wall Street instead and
then once this huge crowd of people were
at Wall Street these people being dumb
as a box of rocks who were just doing
whatever they were told started
protesting Wall Street it was hilarious
to watch they were climbing on the ball
and they were like where the 99 and then
one of the organizers for the Trayvon
protest was like what happened
well you didn't realize these people
didn't show up because they cared about
anything they showed up because people
told them that's what you're supposed to
do these people don't have lights on
upstairs they're just going I don't know
just tell me where to stand and the
Occupy Wall Street activists knew this
I used to I used to tell people this is
really funny
when you'd be when you'd be at a March
in New York City and this is knowledge
for anybody who lives in New York or was
ever near a large leftist March if you
so I'm I'm a journalist and I'm filming
with my camera and I have no interest in
organizing this March the funny thing is
the March is going forward and on
numerous occasions the journalists in
front will turn to the left to get a
wide shot from an angle and the crowd
would follow them and make the wrong
turn down a side street
because all of these people thought was
those people are turning I follow them
the person behind them says I follow him
I follow him I follow him and they all
just March in the wrong way and the
organizers would be like wait wait wait
stop turn around turn around and then
halfway down the block everyone would
stop and get all confused and then start
turning around and then go the other
direction it was hilarious that's what
right foot it's part of why I I hated
religion in my early life is this Faith
blind adherence to Faith Like willing to
believe that whatever we're doing is for
a greater good that I don't even
understand but I'm gonna do it and I'm
gonna follow that guy like that to me is
religion I never liked it I understand
now that you can believe in things that
you can't prove that's not necessarily
evil critical thinking that that element
needs to be there it's yeah yeah yeah
because people will take that faith and
use it for their own Advantage yeah I
would say I would think the religions
that are exactly talking about the ones
that say don't use your critical
thinking don't question us at all like
if you were questioned theoretically if
you're a religious leader you can work
with someone and have a discussion and
your values still surface at the top of
the conversation I think that's true
stronger I think about it this way
imagine there's a group of people in the
middle of the street
and then all of a sudden there's a bang
and every single one of these people
starts running North
what do you do
take care get out of the way Run Run
West yeah get out of the way yeah why
run with the crowd oh yeah no just get
out of the way what you're supposed to
do is take an is assess the situation as
quickly as possible
when so I tell this story about when I
was in Venezuela you're the National
Guard here a few blocks up you had the
protesters there was a bang and the
protesters all started running North
and then I ran West yeah I do not want
to be in between these two groups why
would I run with them but a lot of
people are really dumb so there's a run
in the direction the other people are
running and you see them in the movies
you can be running into the fire a
little show like in the movie of guys in
like Africa running through the Savannah
and like he's getting chased but he just
keeps running straight in a straight
line and the car's gaining on him or
whatever it is right behind you dude run
to the left like do something unique
don't follow along well energy
Prometheus no just Clips the giant ship
is like a donut that's rolling and the
woman runs straight she's like ah and
I'm like run to your right what are you
doing get out from under it it's bad
yeah in your example in your example
these people are thinking I heard a bang
so I have to get away from that they're
not thinking about the other things that
are threatening them they're not
thinking about the danger exactly like
and that's that's wokeness that's crazy
is is wokeness a religion it is a
non-theistic religion okay so it is it
is characterized by a lot of tenets of
of uh I I should say behaviors that are
associated with religion but there's no
core structure or ideology so it's
completely Hollow okay on the outside if
you were to take woke people and a
religious group you'd be like hey they
have very similar Tendencies but then
you would find that wokeness has no
morals they don't believe in morals they
have no core ideology they say random
things and they're dangerous they're
violently adherent to their nothing all
it is is connection to each other if the
group says so you do it in fact
I'm not talking about
religious groups in the sense that they
act like woke people like antifa I'm
saying in the sense that there is a
collective structure and a community
but true religious people are not
mindless zombies mindless zombies can't
have religion but anybody who's watched
this show has seen numerous people who
are devout and and have faith who are
not zombies sure they they like they
think about why they believe this stuff
they have a reason they believe it so I
think it's possible that you know you
this this zombie-like mentality has
existed in many different groups
sometimes it possesses a religion right
now it's possessing a political faction
interesting and it's existed probably
throughout history but with the rise of
social media it's not been as obvious or
prevalent and theoretically if you
control social media right now you can
control the direction of whatever to an
artificial degree right because we've
talked a little bit about the element of
some sort of negative feedback loop here
yeah we can't make it positive yeah I I
don't think there's any kind of positive
outcome from a Mindless zombie cult fair
enough you know like zombies can work
together in in the sense that they all
run in the same direction and will
attack and destroy
but that's the only thing they do so if
your goal is to wipe out a city
unleashing a horde of zombies is a
really great way to do it
San Francisco
or you know if you're China for instance
and you want to uh promote Tick Tock
which then zombifies young people and
creates more people that are Mindless
zombies yeah I haven't seen any creative
value like I see the destructive value
of hordes of mindless people or just not
anyone called mindless but people that
are obsessed with like being victims
like victim mentality that kind of thing
I haven't seen anything creative really
come out of it I've seen movies made
about it that aren't very good
I would say I have seen some creative
things but it's bad it's bad art it's
bad stand up bad comedy bad movies bad
it's awful I think this the mindset that
I'm a victim is just lead leads to
destruction it only can if you think
you're you're at you're you're suffering
and You're Gonna Lose or that you're
losing You're Gonna Lose You you need to
have a positive winning attitude to win
and there's nothing any nobility in it I
mean you know sometimes you see like a
noble martyr I don't see any of that
it's just whiny terrible culture
it's just it's just a mob it's a
pitchfork mob and here we are whining
and complaining about it what it's
infective God that's the problem yeah
but but you must understand uh you can a
controlled burn can stop a wildfire yeah
we're having intelligent conversation
about it right yeah we're picking it
apart
this is why leftists don't go on shows
sometimes you'll get liberals and
left-like individuals they will do it
sometimes but overwhelmingly they don't
because their only goal is to fit in
with the cult you can't do that by going
on someone's show that is not in the
cult all that does is damage your cult
status
there's going to be an interesting
debate coming up with Clint Russell and
a leftist I'm excited about that I think
oh he announced it on the show I think
it was Vox no it's Destiny oh it is
Destiny yeah Destiny's not a leftist he
he's a liberal he's about as Centrist as
you get I love that guy man he's he's
observant and what's up to Steve
yeah he just kind of calls what he sees
I like him that's good yeah I mean he's
a liberal he's been in the show we
disagree on policy but even like before
the show it's like we agree on on a
whole lot because he may have different
political views he leans more
authoritarian than most of us yeah but I
wouldn't I don't know if I'd call him an
authoritarian maybe because he said we
one of the things that really stood out
was when he said a crisis is the perfect
time to force change in a society and
I'm like it's very authoritarian do you
know it is yeah my attitude is like you
shouldn't manipulate people in their
time of need but he was like when else
would you do it and I'm like yeah not in
a crisis when you ask them to vote I
will not it's good that you have this
perspective now you see how the other
side thinks yeah yeah and acknowledging
that that's a good time to do it doesn't
mean that he's instructing people to do
it he's just saying this is when it is
this is when someone don't see an ideal
time to do it and therefore anytime we
go into crisis you can now assume that
there are people who are saying I will
now introduce change there's a big
difference between having it as an
observation and like advice yeah yeah
that's the vibe I get from Stephen
um destiny um is that he's observant of
of a lot of problems but he doesn't seem
to propel them he's pretty uh astute
about let's put him in charge of the the
woke uh the woke mob then so when are he
and Clint uh gonna debate
you know I don't recall what they're
going to debate but it's going to be on
the take Human Action tour do you know
the date is this in Austin no this one's
in this one's in I think Tennessee okay
Clint Russell
Clint Russell I could be wrong it's
Tennessee or New York let's talk about
the end of wokeness how about that we
got this story from timcast.com
Disney's Ultra woke Willow series
canceled after one season oh so uh it's
not just this one show but I'll use this
article as a launching Point Netflix is
getting rid of a lot of these shows they
canceled their their non-binary Ox story
or whatever I don't know if you guys saw
that no yeah it's like a preschool show
where an ox is like I'm non-binary and I
don't like she uh he is she her so I'm
they them and they're like okay and then
Netflix is like get rid of this that is
the worst a non-binary ox for children
so they're starting to get rid of all
this stuff and Netflix is seeing their
subscriptions Grow Again nice so they
they dipped really hard I think this is
evidence that it was the boycott
campaign from conservatives that really
hurt their bottom line and caused them
to shift and go back and I also want to
give a shout out to a show called the
order one of the only shows I've ever
seen where the villain's a communist
interesting season two you'll watch it
they canceled it the fact they were all
like wow on Netflix yeah it's on Netflix
it's called the order and and they did
two seasons and then canceled it but the
second season the bad guy's a communist
he's a communist University Professor
I'll check it out that is no fascinating
yeah like a communist University
Professor is a bad guy I was like this
is great I love I love the show because
I like politics
they even made that like it sounds like
something to be like no it's too crazy I
think conservatives started boycotting
over cuties yeah that was the thing I
think what's happened as as we just did
this long discussion on what wokeness is
these companies are starting to realize
that ESG and wellness hurt your bottom
line good because that's the only reason
they were adopting it I think in the
first place they thought it helped yes
they were like this is what people like
and then and then sure enough if you
implement a Diversity Program at your
company because you want to fit in and
then a year later let's say this let's
say you hired a diversity equity and
inclusion you know a chief Equity
officer or whatever and now Bernie
Sanders just went on Bill Maher and said
we don't want any of that now would he
do fire the guy
whoa we did this thing because on a whim
left us that they liked it now they
don't like it anymore we don't fit in
anymore oh God get rid of it yeah I mean
but think about this Bernie Sanders says
no no we don't want Equity Jen Gilbert
then comes out and says I agree we don't
so if you're a company that has it
you're out of line you no longer fit in
the left is going to throw a brick
through your window because you're so
you're you're opposing Bernie Sanders
now it's too bad these people don't have
self-reflection because they're zombies
with no shame yeah well zombies can't
reflect on anything they've grown you
know but they do have Reflections yes
vampires don't though
there's no way a vampire can see its own
reflect can never reflect on it but you
know vampires can think
yeah like like a vampire is likely
vampires are more like CEOs of big
companies you know big neo-liberal crony
corporate yeah institutions yeah they
just extract value they're conscious of
what they're doing and they don't care
except apparently Vanguard so vanguard's
pulled out of the CSG stuff have you
been following I was not aware that
Vanguard had pulled out of ESG that's
really interesting it's like a 20 how
big is this fund it's about nine times
smaller than BlackRock Vanguard is nine
times it's based out of Pennsylvania
yeah this is American company and the
CEO basically just stepped up and was
like it's not profitable we're done
we're taken back we're aiming at profit
first for our investors we're not going
to screw you guys over by putting your
money into things that don't return
money yeah basic but that's that that's
how economics works that's why I think
why free market a lot of times problem
with free markets is not free it's
co-opted by people at the top it's like
socialism for the few we just we got to
have more economic literacy campaigns so
that people can start to understand it
it's it's going to be a long long haul
but we got to start at the beginning and
just start educate have you talked to
Vivek ramaswamy I have not spoken to him
wow now that would be a unification for
him to come because he is like the
economic Guru that guy yeah to be able
yeah if he can interlock with the
libertarian party he's running as a
republican right now for president he
was just in New Hampshire I think some
of the New Hampshire Libertarians were
were interested in his campaign we'll
we'll see what happens I'm all about
Austrian economics and economic literacy
that's why I'm like so into mises and
that whole you know path
and when you argue with someone who
calls for a command economy or for the
nationalization of banks you're you know
that they've not read anything correct
and they don't know how Finance works at
all it's funny when people talk about
like our tax dollars paying for this
that or otherwise and it's just like
that's not how it works
they just they just manufacture money
it's just it's like a meme it goes Burr
yeah they they the the modern monetary
system is nonsensical it's just like
when they want money it's just there
they have it you just ask Mom and Dad
yeah
if if that the banks just create money
upon demand for a loan exactly the money
supply just keeps growing infinitely and
I heard these people on I was listening
to a space on Twitter and they were like
Finance guys and they're talking about
fractional Reserve policy and I'm like
the FED is we covered this in in 2021 or
whatever yeah like when they get when
Ian brought it up when they dropped the
reserve requirements and that's an
infinite Reserve System where they can
just loan at an infinite number amount
of money with no restrictions exactly
they make it seem as if the fed's doing
it but it's not it's just Banks I mean
if that does it too quantitative
quantitative easing is a thing yes they
want to inject debt-free money into the
system well it's not debt-free but they
want to inject money into the system to
the government things like that but the
uh it used to be a nine to one for every
or like 90 for every 100 they could loan
out 90. and then I think Ian pointed out
they updated in March of 2020 they were
going on to an infinite Reserve System
where Banks could infinitely loan out
money without any any reserve
requirements there's like a lion shares
there there's a quote from the Fed chair
of many at the media Annapolis Fed chair
Neil Kashkari from put it memorably on
60 Minutes in March 2020 quote there's
an infinite amount of cash in the
Federal Reserve we will do whatever we
need to make sure there's enough cash in
the banking system Infinity dollars
so I think that's a good
message to me I'm not giving advice to
anybody to buy Bitcoin and yeah maybe
some gold I mean that's a moronic
statement to say that there is infinite
and that we will do we need to make
enough you can't have enough in an
infinite system it's this is it's like
it's like children just making things up
except these are the people in charge of
our finance yeah it's like it's like
literally everything against what I
learned to get a degree in econ it's
like it's it's totally it's uh we're
just I don't even know what to say when
you were studying for your degree did
they talk about how corrupt stuff was
well I was told that stagflation will
never happen it'll never happen like
this will never be a thing don't worry
about it don't consider it it'll never
happen hey look at that white shot here
we are stagflation how can you define
that really quick uh stagnant stagnating
inflation where of inflation but we
don't have the ability to create any
more wealth out of the situation so you
you there's you're basically just stuck
in a situation it's like this they're
like oh but it'll never happen I was
told so many times it'll never happen
but here so like where you want to buy
steel from a different country but your
money is worth so little that you can't
even afford the steel to buy the factory
so yeah that would be interesting I'll
just I'll just give you the dictionary
definition it's persistent High
inflation combined with high
unemployment and stagnant demand in a
country's economy
costs are going up and everything else
is just Frozen so it's like it's really
bad you can't do you can't do anything
you're stuck just is nothing you can do
you can't affect any change you've got
to find a really cheap way to start a
new industry I like this pulling carbon
dioxide out of the air concept for that
yeah it's a almost in your infinite
resource you know Airborne carbon
more trees just plant burnt trees burnt
trees plant more trees burn trees burn
more trees and more carbon that could
get us like from zero to a hundred uh to
get things started if we need to kick
start our economy but it's not going to
happen with the old style what uh just
somebody uh
some of the chats saying they were this
guy named Blake saying that they were
told that too that sagflation would
never happen that was like a thing that
I was told I would never ever happen
it's never going to be a thing don't
worry about it don't even don't even
think about how to solve it don't think
about it it's never gonna be an issue
then modern monetary policy comes in and
now it's like it's just nmt is like the
Witchcraft of Economics you should not
it's crazy you should not dabble no one
no one knows no one knows what's gonna
happen no one has any real understanding
what's gonna happen because it's all
it's an experiment we're it we're
basically in an experiment right now we
don't really it's it's theoretically
this is how it should work yes
theoretically it's going to be okay but
we don't know modern monetary theory is
the idea that if you control if your
country controls the outflow of money if
you control the currency you can make as
much as you want that you can print as
much as you want and there's no there's
going to be no drawback because you
control it so you can always make more
and nothing can ever stop it or make it
go bad that's the stupid Theory that's
an actual theory that you can print
unlimited amounts of money if you
control it yep that's so so wrong
because you that's a sort of inflation
if you keep it it's printing money
centralizing the economy it means that
you can then
when if if everybody in this table had a
dollar and was trading that dollar for
goods like Ian I'll give you a dollar
for that water and then I have the water
and then Angela's like I'll give you a
dollar for that water and we're trading
this water the money's all moving it's
an economy surge then writes on a piece
of paper one dollar and then walks up
and goes I will give you one dollar for
this water and you go I like this and he
takes your water and leaves now we're
all sitting here holding dollars with no
water and we're like wait what just
happened and we're like he he provided
nothing he did no work for the community
he gave no real trade this is what the
US government has been doing I I
shouldn't say so much the government the
FED what basically happens is we all
work for each other you know what it is
holy crap the best way to understand
this is the Google box from Rick and
Morty all right I don't know what that
is so Rick's car breaks down and then he
has a battery with the mini verse in it
or a microverse whatever he calls it
sure a miniature Universe where a
civilization of people generate energy
by stepping on these pads and then he
takes a portion of energy to power his
car and they don't realize there and
then and then Morty's like extracting
the value yes and Morty goes isn't this
just slavery with extra steps he goes no
no they work for each other they trade
that's what the Federal Reserve is we
all work for each other we all do trade
and then as we're trading these dollars
the dollars have value because we
believe in each other because I know
that Ian wants dollars Ian is willing to
do work for dollars so the economy
functions I say Ian here's a dollar come
on the show and talk about magnetism and
he says that's a good good idea for me
the US government does no work and then
just manufactures the dollar right and
then walks in injects into the system to
take from Ian Ian is then convinced to
do work on behalf of the government who
did no work in return because they
control the flow of money right there
was no value and when there's five value
just extracted from the system it goes
to them they're no value created for the
system at all it's just yeah when
there's four of us each trading a dollar
and then surge comes in with his piece
of paper dollar and hands it in now
we've got four of us that dollar I guess
is lost or we actually no no no there's
five dollars and no water and and one of
the dollars is worth zero so now each of
our dollars is worth 80 cents we have to
divide it up and balance it out remember
that a dollar is a is a store of value
the idea is that it holds value value is
it's like you'd say will bring like a
hundred goats to a market a trade for
like you know a thousand whatever you
just bring it it's a medium of exchange
yeah it's a medium exchange exactly you
don't need it doesn't it's like it just
is represents value so what Tim is
saying is the value is well I'll put it
this way promissory no so Ian
you have a dollar we all have a dollar
and you have the water and we're all
Trading
when search comes to you and says I'll
give you a dollar for your water you now
have two dollars
then when Hannah Claire comes to you and
says I'll give you a dollar for water
you go I already have two I don't need
it
I don't need your dollar I got a dollar
from him
well oh now Hannah Claire can't buy from
you because you're uninterested working
for you I got too much money so then she
has to pay more I said well how much do
I have to give you to do the work and
you go well I already got two dollars so
I don't know two more but it was a
dollar yesterday well I already have a
dollar I don't need yours it's like okay
well I'll give you two dollars no two
dollars is worth it that's inflation
yeah partly what inflation is it's like
how the stagflation starts basically
that's how it begins well the
stagflation is a component of them
stripping resources from the system so
this is rolling businesses yeah there's
something now there's no demand and the
cost of goods are skyrocketing because
they're dumping money basically what
they did was they flood the Zone with
money and then stop anyone from
producing
it was like anyone who's ever read econ
101 would be like that'll cause that
inflation right so the prices are
skyrocketing and the stores are empty
except for Olive surgery professors who
were like that's not a real thing don't
talk about this when they said it would
never happen did they tell you why it
would never happen because no one
thought that anyone would be crazy
enough to say like yeah we can just
print money we can let the banks make
money it's like isn't it this is the
thing we can just you know they're
creating money because they're just
giving it out I'm pretty sure aoc's
policy position on Universal Health Care
is deficit spending there is there's
there are there's more than one monetary
Theory at this point all around just the
creation of money and printing and being
being perpetually in debt I'm pretty
sure aoc's idea was
when you need health care the government
will print the money and pay your bill
yes every time and it's like that's the
fastest way to destroy an economy yeah
increase the deficit yeah I remember
reading that she has a degree in
economics from you know school you know
what would happen the hospitals if they
were told the government will guarantee
all costs no matter what they'll be like
oh really
yeah this guy broke his hand yeah
breaking a hand costs 10 million dollars
to fix right sorry tragic yeah Alexandra
Cortez has an economic degree from
Boston University so no one go to school
at Boston University for economics
unless you want to get into Congress go
to go to The mises Institute instead go
to The mises Institute where's the mises
or just Google Auburn like you do better
off just Googling yeah I wouldn't even
go to school go to the take Human Action
tour and actually learn from an Austrian
economy speaking of Clint Russell and
Destiny will be debating in Nashville
in Nashville and you'll be in Oakland I
will be in Oakland uh I believe that's
in May it's pretty freaking cool we're
having Destiny on the show soon too I'm
pretty sure I'm pumped he agreed to come
on the show earlier but I can't remember
he was watching a clip of one of our
shows he's like I wish I was there
he was talking about in like
interjecting ideas oh yeah that'd be
great he's always welcome he's a smart
dude uh yeah Kyle klinski would be great
as well I'm really excited to get him on
the show at some point and crystal ball
big time yeah love those guys good
people see that's the thing like I
wouldn't call Kyle Kolinski woke okay
like I think I I don't know he's
partisan I mean he's pretty wears it on
his sleeve but he's not woke he seems
like observant to reality he's just he
thinks different like and that's fine
but like if the woke people call me
conservative I probably call you far
right too oh the evil nazi racist
misogynist yeah woman hater woman Kyle I
don't mean you're like super partisan I
just if I had to Levy somebody like I've
seen I think you can be partisan and not
woke yeah I think you absolutely can you
know who was fantastic recently that I
had to I had the pleasure of meeting was
Dennis kucinich oh wow yeah I like that
guy
wonderful person like one of the coolest
guys ever uh former Democrat definitely
not woke former what's he now maybe oh
maybe maybe I'm speaking at a turn maybe
he is still a Democrat but I mean he's
not in office right now he was such a
breath of fresh air in the 2008 election
he kept Obama honest in the running he
he and Ron Paul both were like he spoke
at our anti-war rally and he was just a
delightful human he's still a Democrat
he's just not in office yeah so
definitely not uh woken not one of these
weird uh current things pro-war
Democrats we're gonna go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to timcast.com click that
join us button become a member because
we need your support in this world there
are many evil cultural forces and woke
zombies that seek to destroy and tear
everything down around us if you think
we do a good job if you want us to do
more and you want to see more projects
you like the project to announce such as
the grant program where we're talking
about running I think Benny Johnson
might end up being involved a lot of
work has to be done then become a member
to support us because
so now or never
for those of you that can you should
probably just stand up for yourself
fight the good fight speak out where you
can speak out for those of you that
can't becoming a member is one way it's
not I I gotta be honest I'd rather see
you guys speak up for yourself and take
charge but if there's something holding
you back then I would great I would be
grateful if you became a member and put
us in uh in your charge to help fight
this fight
we got a lot of really cool stuff going
on so I really do appreciate it but
we're gonna have that members only show
coming up at about 10 10 p.m for now we
will read your super chat so smash that
like button
all right I'm not your buddy guy says if
our forefathers were here today they
would say our planet has been taken over
by evil catech and destructive demons
and I'd be unable to disagree man Thomas
Jefferson warned us about the central
banks he said they were more dangerous
than standing armies and he wasn't wrong
he was correct
100 correct unfortunately
all right let's see where are we at
this joke Goldilocks production says
they that can give up essential Liberty
to obtain a little temporary safety
deserve neither Liberty nor safety
Benjamin Franklin historical review of
Pennsylvania 1759 indeed indeed yep
T-Rex bet chap says I don't think
anything else could surprise me with Joe
Biden maybe that's the problem Tim who
do I contact in charge of purchasing for
all the pets oh I guess Ian oh yeah
purchasing all the pets purchasing all
the pets what uh I think they're
purchasing food for the pets yeah food
they um I noticed you messaged me the
other day by the way um
T-Rex Pet Shop you message me uh sorry
about that um I uh didn't know how to
respond pardon me I don't know I'm not
sure who does that so uh that's the
first I've heard of it so T-Rex Pet Shop
is going to send pet food is that the
plan they have uh they have various Pet
Foods yeah we've talked about it before
yeah hit me in search up one of us will
get you through to the right place well
yeah no hit Ian up hit me up on Twitter
I think that's the best way right now
all right billery Clinton says yo Ian is
that Blazer suede or is my TV just
jacked up nah this corduroy thanks for
asking I got some suede ones downstairs
I'll wear one next time
Shannon says Tim your video about the
definition of woke was brilliant and I
feel like I'm armed now if I have to
explain it to someone
thank you
um I think I made the video after the
Tweet or before I can't remember
actually but uh I'm seeing all these
people tweet these long-winded like
academic papers on the definition of
wokeness and I'm like that doesn't
explain it to the average person when
they say woke they are not saying like
when someone goes this guy's woke as
hell they're not saying this guy came to
me and started preaching weird Marxist
economic theories and and racial
theories that were rooted in
post-modernism and the destruction of
the system and the family no no no
you're they're complaining about a cult
member who came up and said nonsense
that's what they're complaining about
they're complaining about someone who is
garbbling word diarrhea it's mainstream
too it's not like deeply esoteric the
key is to hone the definition down to
like six words or less no paragraphs so
that old people that don't have a good
vocabulary can understand it or little
kids can understand it then I will
combine the two sentences that I wrote
if that was too verbose and say
wokeness is the modern left liberal
culture
that has a cult-like adherence to left
to to rapidly changing leftist theories
I think that works
too much leftist too many you use the
word twice I have to only use it once
no there's no other way to say it
we'll have to storyboard this so if
you're talking to an old person like
what does woke mean I would say so you
know there's a left in the right in this
country right there's like conservatives
and liberals or the you know as they say
Okay so the Liberals today
mostly are what we Define as woke and
woke represents a cult-like adherence to
a rapidly changing set of ideologies for
the most part woke basically just means
cult member that's it woke is the name
of the cult
people who are woke are members of that
cult there's no real core structure to
it
that's how I would explain it to an old
person
hence you'll see someone advocating for
removing a child's genitals and they'll
go what
true and I'll be like here is a book
where they are advocating for removing
the genitals of children and they'll go
wow that sounds like a cult yeah it
certainly does doesn't it in a year
they'll say don't do it it's bad and
they'll be like yeah it's bad don't ever
do that yeah that kind of thing yeah
like I'll put it this way if you met
somebody who came to you and said you
were an evil like
if you if if you saw a white person walk
up to a black person and start screaming
the black person who was a white
supremacist
because
the black person opposes cutting off the
testicles of children you'd probably
think the white person was a cult member
or a psychopath that's woke
that's that's what we're talking about
it's that simple and now just because
the worst elements of it are like
removing a child's testicles or breasts
does it mean that all woke people are
that extreme it could also be someone
walk up to and saying call me they them
and you're like ah yes the tenets of
wokeness whose leaders want to mutilate
children's genitals yes so there are
death Cults and there are sex cults
sex cultists don't walk up to you and
try and kidnap you to torture you they
try and comfort you and be nice there
are certain large and prominent
pseudo-religions that I won't name
specifically for legal reasons they
don't come to you and
let me say this
in a totally unrelated story
scientologists don't walk up to people
and then say here's the book on
Scientology they come to you with
dianetics
they ask you if you want to take a test
yes they said you wanna take a take a
test and ask you questions and they say
buy this book called dianetics
if you then go through these steps
eventually you'll find yourself more so
in Scientology that's what wokeness is
so when you see someone who's being very
nice and very polite and they're tactic
totally normal and then they say but
call me they them you're like dude I
don't want to be involved in your cult
have you guys seen the video where
they're all in the park with their hands
up and they're like I will be kind to my
black brothers and that's a cult that's
what a cult is anyway let's read more
all right
dime Kang 86 says apparently there's a
photo on Twitter from Hunter's laptop
that shows Joe Biden with a young woman
Facebook said it violates their child
porn policy what
okay I mean
I know that there are images on the
hunter button laptop that would be
banned from Facebook for that reason
Biden fatigue syndrome not surprised and
no one does anything about it yeah the
system's collapsed everybody knows the
emperor has no clothes and he is well
guarded by cult members in law
enforcement yeah that's why I'm like
Civil War like it's not a civil war it's
a zombie apocalypse okay look
there are zombies occupying the seat of
government
that's it can we have a peaceful
secession from zombie apocalypse the
first Civil War was a peaceful secession
the Confederates declared their
secession the north said no and sent
troops into South Carolina
so yep when you say we want a peaceful
divorce or a national divorce
it is impossible because they will not
allow that I'm going to try to negotiate
a little better I'm going to try to
negotiate a little better
have you tried uh walking up to a mask
antifa throwing bricks and firebombs and
asking them if they would kindly stop
uh
uh I I have a different theory that I
couldn't I couldn't State on on live air
but I do feel like there's a peaceful
way out of it you might be able to
negotiate economic divorce yep I think
we can negotiate economic divorce I
think we got to have more leverage but
but you do you genuinely think there's a
capability to walk up to antifa and talk
them down from where you're building
down no well not I mean well then how
would you negotiate against these people
the the dentist you know has this thing
called you know gas that they share
sometimes sometimes you gotta you know
roofie them and slip away maybe but
that's an act of War what do you mean
well no your self-preservation if
someone's trying to threaten you with a
brick right right so that's what I'm
saying like if it came to the point
where
the rural areas were saying we are
seceding outright there's no question
and then like New York City for instance
has no food and like their water source
comes from the north so if the rest of
New York State said we don't have
anything to do with your crackpot cult
the city would muster up its 30 000
strong police force and say yeah no
you're not taking our water I think I
think you've got to try to negotiate a
little bit better than that I mean
brexit took a long time I think that
there are ways that you can you can
start to weasel your way out of some of
these agreements but it's going to take
time I don't think it's just going to be
hey I'm out but I don't think that
brexit actually accomplished anything in
the long term like I think the whole
thing is just like
if if brexit was a nice vase and the
point was to move the vase from one
shelf to another they threw on the
ground and shattered it sure I want to
do a better job than that but I do think
that it can be done I I am hopeful I am
hopeful
I think the only way it happens is if
it's the left that's the seats I would
love that and I would welcome it if it
was Washington Oregon and California who
declare like when Trump gets reelected
in 2024 let me say that again when Trump
gets reelected in 2024 the West Coast
May likely make those moves I'm a I'm a
big supporter of Cal exit I was before
when I lived there in California even
though I was like Jesus it's not not
going to work out well for me but you
know if it does I'll end up moving I'd
much prefer
um
if if the West Coast were to try to
secede I'd much prefer that Donald Trump
muster the National Guard to occupy them
through military force remove their
governments and recreate constitutional
law in these places and then maybe a
Reconstruction Era
I don't want to compel anyone to stay
with me if they want to leave you know
that uh in the in the Civil War the view
of Northerners was that the people in
the South were being manipulated and
controlled and that they needed to go
down and fight to liberate them from
this correct ideology
horrendously sad yeah and then of course
the South were legit like super racist
and writing about how slavery was a
large component of the new Confederacy I
think despite the fact most people
fighting didn't care about it I think
what's great now is we have the
information age and so it's easier to
share information and get the truth out
all right let's read some more
Jackhammer says Tim Biden illegally
forcing FDIC to cover svb is because
China has a few billion in svb plus
Pelosi and her nephew have millions in
svb no-brainer agreed
so um you know we should start doing we
should start preparing a party for When
Donald Trump gets reelected in 2024. fun
yeah
and then uh and then when he doesn't
they'll come back to this video and take
those clips as if I was being completely
serious I'm just trying to antagonize
the left I don't know what's gonna
happen I don't know if Trump's really
going to win but I do think he's he's
right now based on everything that's
going on Trump is
based on what's happening right now
March 16 2023 I do not see a path for
anyone but Trump however considering the
fact that we're a year and a half away a
lot of variables in there yeah we spend
time in Congress Vivek Rama Swami is
brilliant so he's throwing cold water on
DeSantis
lacks The X Factor
Trump going to East Palestine and Order
McDonald's is The X Factor it is Trump
saying he's going to start a women's
basketball team with a bunch of dudes
identifying as women is The X Factor is
that what he did he said something like
that he's gonna start a women's
basketball team does DeSantis is
DeSantis a brutal owning of Disney not
the equivalent of Donald Trump's X
Factor how would you compare the two I
don't think he owns Disney like
sometimes he's a VP I don't mean like
like literally owns like poned them you
know it was good stuff I mean look on a
scale of one to ten of presidentiality
meaning you have to be presidential to
be on the chart at all right Trump's a
10 and DeSantis is a two I think
interesting from a distance I don't know
Ron but he looks uptight yes
no no as the chair of the national
libertarian party
maybe like he's uh
I would I would much rather see a um
I don't know Michael malice you know I
would love if Michael malice was able to
run I mean he was born out of the United
States but that would that would be my
number Dave pick for the libertarian
party Dave Smith absolutely
I mean is he running
no announcement yet no announcement yet
I mean koi being very Coy over here
Smith two Ray 2024. absolutely that's
good Michael I don't know that's press
secretary I know the challenge is
Warner first pass the post-election
system yep and if I knew that if I went
and voted like if someone said I would
be the judge of the presidency and I
would pick who the president's going to
be at Dave Smith sure no question done
libertarian uh but
we're going to first pass the post
system meaning
I actually like Donald Trump I don't
think he's all that bad I think Dave
Smith would be better but I also don't
want Biden or booty judge or anybody
else to win okay so how about this
Donald Trump is winning a landslide your
vote doesn't matter because
Ronald Reagan numbers then then can we
maybe get a Libertarian yeah but how do
we know that
well I'm waving a magic wand at this
point see the thing is a lot of people
have said to me like Tim you can't keep
voting for the loss of two evils and I'm
like I don't think Trump is the lesser
of two evils at all yeah I mean the
first time I saw Trump I didn't care for
him I thought he was a bad character and
stuff then I actually saw what he was
doing then I saw him do more foreign
policy wise than any president we've
ever had and I'm like he's just good
enough I do think he's the lesser of two
evils because of operation warp speed I
don't think he handled the lockdowns
correctly and he also increased uh
Federal uh
what would I call it a federal gun uh
yeah Banning bump stocks yep
not good so I look at it like not as bad
as Biden absolutely not he's the first
president where I've seen a net positive
despite all the massive negatives I
think that's a reasonable take like I I
imagine a Dave Smith presidency would be
like 80 positive 20 negative yeah
because no one can you can't there's no
perfect president but Trump I've felt
was like I don't know 55 45 or 60 40
sure like like bomb stock band bad
things things like that but man Abraham
Accords woof
Afghanistan withdrawal oh boy yeah try
I'm trying to have negotiations with
North Korea he crossed into the DMZ into
North Korea with no security detail it's
not it's very impressive it's bold that
was a tremendous tremendous move let's
read some more super jets so yeah I mean
that's why I'm kind of like I I'll take
a trump you know I I I I I dig it you
know
but uh it's tough because a year ago I
was saying to santis because Trump was
just crying non-stop on the internet
about 2020 and I was like really on turn
off but now we're starting to see that
energy come back yeah I got to tell you
that Trump's favorability for me jumped
substantially with the McDonald's in
East Palestine I think that really was a
major moment for him and you know what
politicians should be taking a note on
that seriously
um DeSantis wasn't there he couldn't be
he's not running Vivek wasn't there
Marion Williamson wasn't there and I'm
like come on any one of these people Joe
Biden wasn't there shout out to Benny
Johnson who showed up who took the 20
grand he made that month in profit and
gave it to the people yeah like I know
that was that's incredible I'm like how
is it that you gave more money than
Biden dad I cannot wait for the for the
primary debates RFK Jr versus Marianne
Williams that's awesome it's gonna be
fun oh good all right all right where
are we with these super jets
all right Tony Ty says find a cure for a
liberalism fund and then a little golden
ribbon
a cure for liberalism the problem is
liberalism is a good thing yeah I don't
know uh liberalism is an actual academic
reference to a good thing the problem is
what we refer to as Liberals are weirdos
like like but we just use the word
liberal for that yeah
yep
all right
Mike E says daily dose of wisdom asked
AI to write a letter as Jesus to his
church AI called out the progressive
church and Prosperity Gospel as wrong
teachings wow
post a screenshot of that I'd love to
see it yeah be cool that is nice
all right Cody Scofield says I'm Jewish
where's my reparations from Germany
Egypt or the Democratic party for FDR
turning the boat of Jews back during
World War II snap didn't Germany
actually pay reparations though I think
they have yeah you just got to call them
2014. I think yep yep
all right
what do we got here let's grab another
one
reggae Vibe says I'm fourth generation
Californian my wonderful state was has
ruined my state is that what it was
ruined my state the Locust that moved in
will move on to your places too
including West Virginia Tim beware
yeah I never encourage leftists to move
out of California I'm like you should
stay there I I'm happy for you that
you're you're just getting it the way
you want it just hang out what's the
excuse for any of it for for why it's
falling apart despite getting everything
you ever wanted no joke I have people
tell me that it's too conservative
I'm being dead serious I've heard that
too it's it's it's not real Democrats
it's it's these fake Democrats who are
Republicans here's what we should do we
should take a couple a couple billion
maybe a hundred billion
set up a private island and create a
communist Utopia for them
100 billion dollars we already spent it
in Ukraine imagine if we just did one
time and then asked every single leftist
to go and live on that island in their
communist Utopia we built it just for
you
I feel like then they'd be like no no we
need to stay here because you guys need
to be saved from how to walk acapella go
too I think they'd say yes
I think some would but I think enough
would feel as though they would like be
able to justify staying by saying and
then within like six months they'd burn
the whole thing down and kill each other
yeah it would be like Fire Island but
yeah but but it would be like Lord of
the Flies like Cuba yeah yeah I'd be
like Cuba what president has been has
been said that you think that everyone
would just suddenly burn the entire
place down I think if you went to a
young leftist communist Marxist or
whatever and said we have decided you
are right and we're allocating funding
to build a state where you can run the
things the way you know they they're
supposed to be
and then once it works we're going to
implement it everywhere else they're
going to be like we won yay they're all
gonna go have people sign up all those
people in chat all of them yep every
single one and then a year later it will
be a slum covering the fee season live
they all have typhus they'd be starving
yeah yeah it would collapse in two
seconds and then what we do is we
blockade the island you know you can't
leave you got food you got you know you
got a big on I'm not saying like a
little one like a big one they'll be
farmland and stuff yeah you know like
you don't really know how to farm I
assume right that doesn't help them you
guys always you finally got uh the real
socialism and real communism you always
wanted there you go I mean who said they
need to try I don't know it's it's
finally been tried it's officially
finally real communism has been tried
and officially it would be funny if like
six years later they're like flying to
the Moon in spaceships and they all have
like perfect health and they can
levitate and float and they're
enlightened with big pulsing brains and
they're like we have achieved peace
luxury gay space communism that's yeah
all right
Joe spinel says Tim you're over defining
wokeism wokism is a euphemism for useful
idiot that doesn't explain anything to
anybody an old person comes to you and
says what is this woke I keep hearing
about and you're like basically modern
liberalism and they they behave like
they're in a cult that's about it
they're violent they're aggressive they
complain a lot
I like to go along with the current
thing because that's a real basic view
that's basically what it is they follow
current thing with cult like adherence
yep modern leftist liberal culture that
follows current thing the thing is what
does current thing mean like it changes
it is in and of itself a meme and
current thing basically means like
modern narrative whatever they're
focused and fixated on so that means
they could be against the military
industrial complex yesterday but if
today the news story is about being in
favor of Ukraine they will support it
it makes no sense
it's a cult there you go
track media only says woke is multiple
ideologies that is why they eat each
other when one steps out of the other's
ideals
but that's the point how can Welk be
multiple things at once it's because
it's not it's not any of these things
that's why you can be woke without
actually knowing or understanding any of
the ideologies
like if someone walked up to you and
started talking about non-binary
cartoons and how you're a bigot you'd
call them woke but then if you ask them
about anything related to post-modernism
critical theory they say I have no idea
what you're talking about you can even
ask about schools they might even say
that stuff shouldn't be in schools okay
well how is that because they don't know
what they're talking about yeah it's
more of a behavioral description science
and control snowball going downhill and
catching all these things in it
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
talking to a bud last night we're like
so happy to be raised in an area in in
an era 80s 90s where racism was a thing
of the past America was moving on now
it's a complete-ish show can we please
go back I don't think racism was a thing
of the past in the 80s and 90s I think
it was really bad he had the crack
epidemic the CIA and all the stuff the
riots Rodney King rights yeah absolutely
and uh there was a period I think in the
end of the 2000s where things were
getting decently better and then Obama
came in and was like I'm gonna make it
all worse yep and then he did and
everybody you look at the polls people
believe Obama actually made things worse
hope and change yep thanks I think it
was blowing up kids Obama came in and
said you want for me I'm gonna blow up
kids
and then they voted for him and he blew
up kids and then in 2012 he was like I
know you liked it the first time you
vote for me again I'm gonna blow more
kids and everyone's like yeah and
they're holding signs saying blob kids
that's that was the whole Obama presence
yeah yay blowing up kids yeah thanks
Obama
when you make t-shirts like that
actually he blew up kids man a lot of
them that's crazy
America not like Trump did not get me
wrong just Obama was worse it's weird
that's a weird thing to want to get
elected to do I mean Obama didn't
literally say vote for me and I'll blow
up kids but he literally blew up kids
like a week within getting elected the
first time it was it clearly it was on
his mind he knew he was doing it and he
kept on doing it I mean Abdullahi is the
is the definitive he'd blow up a kid
we're both doing the Bill Clinton thumb
have you know well I mean Obama did too
did you do it too yeah that's why I was
doing it listen I noticed it with Bill
Clinton
he learned it from yeah Sheamus had the
best line we were talking about it he
was like too many he's like he vote for
me we're gonna blow up kids too many of
them gotta blow him up and I'm like
that's that's a good one you got to make
that cartoon Sheamus
all right where are we at with these
super chats we just had uh one it just
jumped because YouTube likes doing it
all right get a pair with Sully says I'm
a Minnesota mises caucus member and I'll
be speaking at the Minnesota house
elections committee tomorrow Minnesota
dams made a bill to keep third parties
off the ballots and major party status
SF 1827 and HF 2802 how is that legal
these people suck these people suck they
do this all the time they tried to do it
in Texas recently they are desperate to
stay in positions of power they don't
want to get knocked off
they're very much afraid to lose uh to
the other to the other side so what I'm
doing uh with the libertarian party and
rage against the war machine uh rally
group is where we're launching operation
Warhawk to ruin some of the worst
neocons and warhawks in their primary
election season and and people who do
this kind of crap they're going to be
under my my eye as well viral media
campaign wreck them
all right Pablo papano says Ian turns
the frogs gay graphion is new seed oil
Frog's hot for that all right everybody
if you hadn't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member over at timcast.com
because we need your support as members
you help make this whole operation run
smoothly and all of our dreams and goals
for expansion and fighting the culture
War can only be possible if you guys
Believe in Us as well so if you do
believe in us and you want to see us
fight even harder and do more become a
member because I'll tell you this if we
had like 10 million dollars overnight
I'd hire like 70 people instantly but
it's not that easy you know tracking
budgets making sure we have enough in
you know right now with ad rates
dropping it's like okay so expansion is
going to slow and a lot of things we
want to do are going to get are slowed
up and it's already been difficult
enough but uh you know it is what it is
hey there's another option that I know
everyone's going to say no to selling a
portion to the company for a large
influx of investment so that we can
rapidly launch new projects the problem
is investors come in and they contain
the company so we're in a difficult
position where we have a serious
opportunity for investment because the
company is so successful but the problem
then is seating control outside of just
me could result in the company going
like getting tainted and so that just
means we move more slowly
if everybody who watched this show every
single person became a member we would
be the biggest media company overnight
I'm not even kidding if every single
unique viewer who watches show signed up
which doesn't happen we would be the
biggest media company on the planet
period no question no question at all
but uh you know that it is what it is I
think Netflix has like tens of millions
of Subs paying members so they get to
make whatever they want all the time
it's good news that they're getting rid
of the woke stuff but anyway become a
member we're gonna have that members
only show coming up smash the like
button share the show you can follow the
show at timcastirl you can follow me
personally at timcast Angela do you want
to shout anything out absolutely if
you're interested in joining the
libertarian party please go and visit
lp.org I'm going to be speaking in
Austin Texas next month at the Inc in
independent National Convention so if
you're interested in getting in politics
and you hate the two parties and you're
still skeptical of the lp come on down
to that April 3rd through 5th you can
find me on patreon uh sub stack and
locals right on cool I'm Hannah Claire
brimlow I'm a writer for timcast.com you
should follow at timcast news on Twitter
and Instagram it's the best you see work
for me and all of our other journalists
if you want to follow me personally you
can follow me on Twitter at HC brimelow
and you can also follow me on Instagram
at hannahclair.b beware of imposters oh
yeah handclare.bb I hear was an imposter
account and B1 they give out crypto
advice so I guess if you want that
girl's take so just report those
accounts if you see it's my handclare.b
I reported it and Instagram is still
like well we're thinking about it we're
not sure yet we'll look into who you are
oh my gosh uh you know Angela you
mentioned take human actiontour.com uh
I'll be speaking in May May 13th in
Oakland so if you guys want to get
tickets for that it's take human
actiontour.com and also I have another
speaking engagement coming up at the
minds Fest uh in April April 15th that's
going to be in Austin we'll be doing a
live IRL the night before and then we'll
be doing stage work on the 15th so you
can get tickets there at Vulcan it's
tickets Dot
vulcanpresents.com and you'll have to
search for the dates it's April 15th and
see you there
I am surge.com I'm going to zoom in
really fast here
yeah anyways all right well we got news
Discord is ready and is about to go
public solid so the official Discord for
timcast.com members if you sign up at 10
bucks you'll get access to the general
chat if you are a member of timcast.com
for longer than six months you should
have instant access to the VIP Suite if
you want to join the VIP Suite it's 25
bucks a month we got to figure out how
that works because I'm sure after six
months of being a member at 25 you could
drop down or something but what to
figure out how that works the point is
we just want to keep out you know
activists who are trying to attack us
weirdos who are trying to put fake
things in there and then smear us so we
needed some kind of gates time or money
we tried both because we want to be as
Fair as possible
and then we're gonna have the 100 per
month elite VIP Club members only where
we will have uh timcast employees
hanging out you can talk to people who
work here and then we're trying to make
that something bigger so it's not just a
Discord chat room it'll be like a
component of our of our private club so
that we can build some kind of community
that um you know does something more you
know maybe maybe uh I don't know we'll
figure it out there could be advice we
can send pitches and things like that we
got to figure it out but yeah that club
should be there and it should be live in
the next few minutes I don't exactly
know how that works or how you get
access to it because they just finished
it right now while I'm sitting here but
uh I'm sure once I get up and go look
they'll be like oh yeah just tell people
to do this and it should be fairly
obvious so we'll have that set up live
momentarily so please become a member if
you want to hang out it'll be a 24 7
chat hangout and uh it will be moderated
we do have rules the purpose of the
Discord server is to have legitimate
academic conversations on cultural
issues policy and things that are
impacting our world for the better or
for the worse to share news and ideas I
will use it as a resource so if you're a
member of the elite club and you want me
to cover a story I might not know what
stories happening you could send to me I
could be like whoa I didn't know that
and other other Tim cast writers might
see that stuff as well
not to mention like the the VIP room
which is time more money gated you can
voice chat for the after show too so
we're really excited about that I'm
legitimately excited for that component
because that's going to be really
awesome is this tonight are we is it
ready you think tonight no because we
have to get it it's ready to go live for
people to sign up but I don't think we
have it yet on our system cool but then
for the members only uncensored stuff we
could have some crackpot weirdo like
that the goal with the the gate either
money or time is to prevent crackpot
weirdos because we don't want some like
far leftists coming in and then being
like Baba Booey Baba Booey Howard
Stern's penis or whatever although that
that would be that'd be kind of funny
but like we don't want to say something
crazy but the point is it'll be on the
uncensored show so maybe who cares it
might be funny if antifa showed up and
said some weird crap but we could argue
with them
that'll be fun so I'm really excited for
this we're gonna have to get the members
only set up right now thanks for hanging
out we'll see y'all there